it's friday
it's the end of the week that means it
means all of the worst
possible stories for corporations and
the government come out today
it's fantastic we have some of the most
important news to bring you
but everybody's out partying and that's
kind of the point because the jobs
report got released
it is the worst miss in 23 years
unemployment went up
and now all of a sudden the blind
administration joe biden himself he's
like well
okay you know look we're dealing with
the pandemic and you know you know it's
nothing to do with unemployment payments
and cnn writes an article saying the the
country is still reeling from the
pandemic
last month when the job report was good
when jobs were
you know unemployment was going down but
in celebrating saying see look what our
administration is doing
now that it's getting really bad they're
acting like it's not their fault
surprise surprise
here's where it gets really screwed up
one of the reasons
the jobs report is so bad is that
unemployment right now is paying an
average of 16
an hour so nobody wants to go work and
the people who do
can't because many of them who do have
kids and they can't send their kids
anywhere they've got schools
joe biden's response we're gonna give
everybody more money
great that's just gonna make the economy
worse off
i think it's pretty obvious what they're
doing so uh yeah in other news
federal charges were just uh laid out on
the uh minnesota police officers chauvin
and the three other cops so they're
getting charged again at the federal
level
and uh forgive me for being a bit
pessimistic but man
i hope you all have uh gotten ready for
whatever might be coming
maybe that just means chilling putting
some bitcoin aside or something i don't
know advice from me but
i certainly am well we'll talk about all
this joining us today is the man who
almost took down joe rogan you were so
close dave
comedian dave smith what's going on tim
thanks for having me back
and uh i almost got joe but i will get
you tonight all right excellent
oh boy uh for those for uh for those
that don't don't understand the
reference
you were on with joe when the media did
that huge thing about his
vaccine comments yeah but it wasn't
really me i was i got him going about
other things if you had asked me after
that podcast
what was going to get you in trouble i
would have named 20 things
before the clip that they picked but you
know they went with what they were
medium matters is watching
yeah like santa claus they know when
you're sleeping they know what you're
saying we got bill
ottman he's still hanging out here hey
here we are thanks for joining ceo of
mines you wanna do a quick
quick intro yeah what's up guys bill ceo
of mines
along with ian co former co-founder now
hanging out in the castle
how is he a former co-founder no yeah
spank me while i'm down phil he went
back in time and
and told himself not to do it you saw
looper
looper yeah that was a very high drop
sound that that kid made
oh no i really you know the movie
blooper you ever see that yeah i never
saw it but i'm
familiar yeah it's worth seeing the
guy's like a super villain
went back in time bruce was bunch of
that nonsense super villain oh that's
right that kid
yeah yeah yeah okay all right the story
of donald trump i know basically
and ian is here yes oh well thank you
tim yes ian crossland what's up
everybody glad to be here
yeah and i am also here wish me luck
pushing buttons for all these mad men
tonight
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started i have a huge announcement first
you must go to timcast.com and become a
member
to get access to our exclusive members
only
library of content we got so many
podcast episodes we got like full hours
with some of your favorite people like
james o'keefe and michael knowles
talking about things like
how to stand up for yourself why we must
resist the establishment lies
we've got a couple big updates notably
if you click that big old beautiful
members only button
you can see you can now pay with stripe
so for everybody who is saying i don't
want to sign up with paypal you have
another option here
definitely check it out but if you go to
store you will see something truly
incredible
there is a new product in the
timcast.com store
it is called to the moon and it is
modeled off of the i am a gorilla shirt
because apparently that's the thing
we're doing now
and it is a sheba with coins bursting
out from behind him holding
stacks of cash and it says to the moon
it's a reference to dogecoin so if you
want to get your to the moon and then to
mars it says
in the in the url you can get your silly
uh dogecoin shirt
i i ended up making this one simply
because i was convinced and i ended up
buying dogecoin i'm not telling anybody
to go buy dogecoin
but you should buy the shirt i'm allowed
to give advice to people when it comes
to me selling merch
apparently you can't give financial
advice so it's like if you if you want
a shirt isn't that weird you can push
what is clearly a depreciating asset
but if you tell someone to go buy
something and go i think this might make
you some money then they'll be like all
right you're giving financial advice but
what's the real issue you get sued or
something
i don't know false hope i wonder if
that's just a meme to be honest
yeah i know there's a lot of people who
are in finance
whenever they talk about something
they'll always go now i'm not giving
financial advice
but i'm just saying there might be
advertising law around it
or people could be like they gave advice
and i lost money so i'm suing you
maybe is that it can they sue you but i
can say this
don't buy dogecoin buy the dogecoin
shirt
oh so you can't no so what happens if
you're like
he said not to buy bitcoin and then i
didn't and then bitcoin went up you know
a thousand percent
i demand that money that'd be the best
lawsuit ever
you did not tell me how to get rich yeah
right
how dare you all right let's uh let's
let's talk about this this first
story and uh man
we live in truly the dumbest of times i
suppose the daily mail runs this story
why no one needs to work in biden's
america
experts project anyone who earned 32 000
before covet could now earn more in
benefit staying home
the average weekly unemployment benefit
is now
638 dollars 300 more than what it was in
2019
that means people are earning around 16
an hour
more than double minimum wage which was
at least 725 across america
not even that if you're living in new
york and you're getting 15 bucks an hour
working fast food you're like
might as well just quit i'll get a raise
yeah
raise them don't work so this is all
this is this so they say it's creating a
nightmare scenario for the economy
businesses are desperate to recover from
the pandemic but they can't fill their
jobs
the funny thing is there are 7.1 open
jobs
i guess that's like the number that
comes from the government 266 000 jobs
created in april
because people are going in they're like
how much do you pay and they're like
15 an hour and they're like meh i'm
going home you said 7.1
million jobs billion jobs are open right
now looking for people to work
and there's nobody wants to do it i know
i know at least
five people who are doing the
unemployment thing knowingly
avoiding work yeah because of it well
this is actually i don't blame them
not every single person so when i was i
think i was maybe 20 or 21 i got
unemployment for losing a job
and the people at the unemployment
office literally told me
not to take a job that was paying less
because it creates a dependency so like
i was talking to them and they're like
look look for work
we don't expect you to take a really low
paying job because the fear is that if
you can't support yourself you'll just
be right back here on the phone again so
find a real job it's like oh okay
all right that's they told me they were
like otherwise we just get too many
people
who keep taking bad jobs and can't
sustain themselves what do you think's
happening now people are getting 16
bucks an hour
they're like there's no way i can take
15 bucks an hour because i can't pay my
bills right getting more unemployment
and i think it's actually a bit worse
than that because if you if you actually
think through the logic
of the economics of it right it's not
just that if you're getting paid 16
an hour to do nothing that doesn't just
mean like oh okay well i'll only take a
job for seventeen dollars an hour that
means that a job at seventeen dollars an
hour is effectively a job at one dollar
and
exactly that you have to work for one
dollar an hour a job at twenty dollars
an hour is
four dollars an hour plus you got to get
up every day plus you got to pay for gas
or
transportation or this so now it comes
back down i mean you you
it really throws the incentives wildly
off
there's good news here though because
the uh backdoor ubi experiment
has proven it doesn't work and so let's
just get ubi out of there sorry sorry
ubi enthusiasts
i think joe joe is a ubi enthusiast yeah
well
it's a question of who it doesn't work
for you know i mean it certainly doesn't
work for the taxpayer
i suppose it works for the people who
are collecting these benefits
temporarily
but what does it actually do long term
you know if you can just imagine like
imagine if we were just on a desert
island
somewhere and you were like okay we're
all poor we're on this desert island we
gotta work
someone's gotta pick fruit someone's
gotta fish someone's gotta build shelter
we gotta work
and then someone else said well i'll
just uh i got paper
in my pocket i'll supervise and i'll
just yeah i'll supervise and i'll start
diving out the paper amongst us and they
go don't worry you're really wealthy
because i gave you this money
that's basically the game that we're
playing right now where it's like
it's less and less people actually
producing anything well but we can
pretend we all have wealth because we're
passing around these paper federal
reserve notes well this actually is
extremely beneficial to
you know the great reset davos group
kind of people because think about it
right now they have created a system in
which
people will make more money not working
which means no consumption no plastic no
pollution no waste no gas being used no
carbon emissions just people sitting
around being like oh
and the best part is they're dragging
everyone else down with them
so it's like it's the ultimate crabs in
a bucket
the only issue is the crabs you know
crabs in a bucket has crabs in a row
right whenever a crab tries to get out
the other crab pulls it down that
implies that one crab is like hey you
can't leave or i'm gonna climb out of
you to escape
in this instance it's people just being
tied to the other
like all the crabs are tied together so
when a bunch of crabs were like nah
we're better off in the bucket don't
leave
the ones that actually want to do better
are being weighted down by those who
don't
what's happening basically is people got
to understand this dollars are
meaningless
a dollar is just the current
representation of the value of the labor
you've traded
and it only really matters that day
because the value keeps changing because
it's a deflate you know it's what is an
inflationary currency it devalues itself
over a long period of time
so you go and work you get 10 bucks if
you sit on that money it becomes worth
less every single day
the reason it is because the government
just prints and borrows money so what's
happening is
you create value with your labor let's
call it a unit of labor one hour you
create one hour
and then someone comes up to you and
says i'd like to trade you one hour of
my labor
the only problem they didn't actually
have any real labor behind that dollar
because the government just printed it
and gave it to them
so the total amount of value in the
system stays the same
but the total amount of trade currency
to to exchange value keeps going up
yes and if i could take that a step
further because you're absolutely right
if you were to uh enslave somebody
and take an hour of their labor i
enslave you for an hour and i take you
were a slave for that hour that unit of
your hour
well i was ill-gotten by me because i
enslaved you yeah but if you work for
that hour and you get one
unit of federal reserve notes and then i
print that money away and
slowly and slowly steal it from you what
have i really in effect done
other than retroactively enslaved you
for the time that you were yes but
you're still happy
well for for a little bit i don't know
this country this country doesn't seem
that happy to me
yeah but for stupid reasons for for like
the stupidest of reasons
they think nazis are running around
everywhere it's like have you gone
outside that's just not reality you know
in addition to what you guys are talking
about about the value of labor and the
federal reserve note
representing that not only are they
printing more notes and hoarding them so
that the value of the actual
note to labor ratio is devaluing but
people
aren't actually doing labor that's my so
there's even
less value that's what i just said and
and so
it's one thing like after world war ii
modern monetary policy printed a bunch
of extra money so that they could create
production
to then pay off the debt that they that
they created right now we're just
printing the money without the
production creation
but they're probably doing it for the
same reason so a lot of people talked
about how these blue states had massive
debt
and then they're like we better pump
trillions of dollars into the economy
right and then shut down all the small
businesses so only the massive
multinational corporations take all that
money
well i'll tell you one of the huge
differences right okay so
after world war ii as we were talking
about before right there's every
industrial country in the world was
destroyed in war except america i mean
we fought the war abroad but we weren't
destroyed
at home our productive capacity was
intact and on top of that we had the
bretton woods agreement
so there was some limit to the amount of
money that the the
government could print after 1971 when
richard nixon
richard nixon took us off the gold
standard then it really became a
free-for-all where we could just print
as much money as we want and a lot of
times left-wing people will point
back to the early 70s as this time where
even bernie sanders i think point
points to this sometimes or he goes you
know since the 70s
wages haven't kept up with productivity
and all of a sudden the real super rich
are getting really really rich
and the working class doesn't have the
same rise in standard of living
and this is what it all comes back to is
that if you have a government that can
print money out of thin air with
absolutely nothing
to to restrain it you're going to get an
awful crony fascistic economy it's
really simple man
you are sitting there holding a big
beautiful cheeseburger that you cooked
for yourself
and i walk up and i have a rock in my
hand and i say trust me this rock is
valuable i'll give you this rock for
your cheeseburger and they're like
deal and then you're then you take that
cheeseburger you gave them nothing for
it
but they think it's valuable or it's
just
slowly eroding the value away so the
government can come in do no real work
buy things convince people to do things
services labor resources
and they're not putting anything into
this right well listen this is what ron
paul used to always say which i think is
like the best way to look at it right
is that all the government can do is tax
now there's three forms of how they can
tax you they can just
tax you in which case you pay your taxes
or they can borrow money which is
basically just a promise that they'll
tax you in the future
or they can print money which is in
effect attacks because it robs the value
of your money
it's all says those things dave he still
says this he's not dead yet
that's a good point he still he says
them more than ever but what i mean is
when he was when he was running for
president he used to make these points
you're right the great ron paul still
says these things
but the point is that the government if
you just think about it like this and
the terms you were laying out right
all that is happening is there's
production that's how wealth is created
as things
people produce things they work the
government doesn't produce
anything all they do is take from us
bureaucracy
they're really good at making
bureaucracy yes but bureaucracy does not
produce anything yeah
we have to pay for the bureaucracy now
hold on there a minute
uh dave couldn't uh an average working
joe like myself just
learn these rules and exploit this
system to benefit
in much the same way the wealthy do well
how would you do that
well so you understand how they they
they deflate these currencies and things
right
or i'm sorry they inflate the currencies
they devalue the currencies so
if you take out a really massive loan
and put your money into a hard asset
that will appreciate say property
then when the dollar continues to become
worthless the debt you owe to the bank
is substantially worth less as well so
the rich people who are holding
debt in dollars the value of that debt
is diminished
but the hard asset stays the same i feel
like you're just telling me your life
story but
yes to your ready well yeah look if you
can get access to a loan then yeah
certainly there are things that you can
invest in that could perhaps
be a hedge against inflation or there's
a you could invest in precious metals or
in
cryptocurrency or something like that
but regardless of that
the vast majority of people probably are
not going to invest in those that's the
point they're out there working
and basically supporting if you wonder
you know there's
it's funny because sometimes uh people
like bernie sanders
is just the example it keeps popping in
my head but he'll say these things like
he'll be like
did you know that you know the the of
the new money created you know whatever
the numbers are 90
has gone to the top one percent or
something like this and he's right
like his numbers are right but you look
at what we've had since obama
say really since 2008 to now we've had
record high government spending
more higher government spending than any
government in the history of the world
and interest rates have basically
remained around zero the whole time
and that's what's leading to all of this
but but isn't it true
that by creating this system a wealthy
individuals
or people of even modest wealth are able
to
hedge their money retain value devalue
their loans
and thus it keeps the rabble out of
politics you know we can't have poor's
running around actually dictating how we
do things in this country could you
imagine what
what you're watching the patriot
recently i'm joking by the way but you
watched the patriot recently
and you have i think it was cornwallis
and he was like you must stop targeting
our officers
could you imagine what war would be like
without gentlemen
like that's kind of that's that's i feel
like that's kind of the attitude because
what we're seeing with this kind of
policies
like so joe biden actually is saying
right now after all this comes out he's
like
no i think we should print more money
you know why
rich people they their their their their
assets are in
you know their their their value their
their money is not in dollars
so when one dollar tomorrow is now only
worth the equivalent of 50 cents
well they're holding gold or they're
holding bitcoin or they're holding
property in real estate the loans to the
bank go down for all the rich people
and the poor people but the poor people
also don't have any money to begin with
so if you're of modest means and you've
got you know a thousand bucks in the
bank
tomorrow you got 500 worth in the bank
your loans may be only worth half as
much but you still don't have any money
or any appreciating assets
so the things you do own you're you're
not really gaining all that much your
job isn't now paying you more money all
of a sudden
so they're they're printing out
unemployment at 16 bucks an hour
so nobody is producing anything but
they're still demanding things
they are rapidly deflating the economy
which i'm sorry devaluing yeah yeah i
keep mixing it up
and so what's going to happen is the
rich are going to get richer at rocket
speed
and the poor are going to get poorer at
rocket speed that's it's right there we
saw last year with amazon
i don't know what their actual value is
off the charts
unexpected i mean if you really thought
about it you would have seen it coming
but
look at this we here at tim cast irl are
relegated to drinking rc cola
what are the economies i'm just kidding
tim's been very excited to shout out
i'm like i make sure that we don't get
that garbage in this house
that was actually an upgrade for uh for
tim cast was we were finally you've
making enough money you can pull off the
rc cold that's actually true yeah
because most people would just go to the
store and get what they can
yeah and it's going to be covered at
this point you got to work so ordered
the rc man well look i mean what what
drives me crazy about it is
every single time when these politicians
joe biden does it all the time when he
says well you know
it's the pandemic that destroyed all of
these
jobs i mean let's get real it's not the
pandemic it's not the virus that
destroyed the economy
government lockdowns well no it's not
even china
and it was the chinese government by the
way who allowed the pandemic to get out
right like there were chinese
doctors who blew the whistle on this
whole thing and they're somewhere in a
chinese prison right now if they're
still alive
but it was our own government even
forget what china did
it was our own government that locked
down our economy and destroyed it
they're still locking down the economy
in most of these blue states
and they're still destroying the economy
even when there is no
even plausibly uh reasonable
scientific argument to do so i mean like
you you look at florida and texas and
the fact that they're open back
up and that they're doing better than
the national average despite what fauci
predicted would happen when florida and
texas opened up
and the fact is that we're basically at
a point now with covid
where even though i mean look this was
obvious from about april 2020 but
right now about 50 of the adult
population has been vaccinated
of the other 50 who hasn't been
vaccinated i i've seen
estimates from 30 to 60 percent have had
covet at some point and have some
natural immunity to it
on top of that we basically know now
that asymptomatic spread is
very very low if it happens at all so
the idea of these super spreader events
are
pretty much over like that that's just
not what matters because the tv doctor
said so well that's right dr phil uh
epidemiology department
says that uh we we have to keep locking
down but
so all of this is now self-imposed or
government impossible it was almost it
was always though yeah but we're
we're almost beyond this because now if
you look to texas in florida that are
doing really well
they are still going to be harmed by the
current economic policies of
we're going to give everybody 16 an hour
equivalent unemployment
and so that means people in texas are
going to be like why do i why should i
work
yeah the response to this has been
absolutely insane it makes me
exactly what you're describing just now
makes me think sometimes when people get
severely ill or something like with
cancer and then they take some sort of
radiation therapy like chemo and the
chemo ends up doing more damage to their
body and and
destroying their body and they die right
but they're not always
but if that's sometimes if something
that were to happen they would call it a
cancer death
even though the medication was so toxic
that maybe it was a
medic the medication killed the person i
i always measured as a cancer death
for the most part i feel like the
response to the covet
thing has done more damage than covet
did
there's only seems like listen i don't
like that argument because there's only
so much we can do
as human beings trying to trust the
experts the issue now is that you have
texas and florida doing really really
well so it's not this argument about
cancer and chemo
and you know oh the doctor said this no
it's like literally texas and florida
have opened up
many other states haven't even shut down
i think south and north dakota's
economies have actually grown a little
bit
relative to and and they're seeing
similar covert rates so now it's it's
about time to maybe
get back to business and maybe have some
some protection for the
the weak the vulnerable you know the
people with the immuno compromised and
we had done that a long time ago
but we're not even it's not even
necessarily about the pandemic at this
point
the issue is we're supposed to be
getting back to work they've
administrated how many vaccines like 100
million or something and they're still
the problem is in march we saw this
massive job growth and joe biden was
clapping for himself
patting himself in the back and now
they're still saying they're going to
ramp
up unemployment why i thought
like so west virginia just announced the
mass mandate's going away it's that's it
they're
done with it texas and florida reopened
up people starting to reopen
so now we're in an economic economic
policy issue
that has nothing to do with the pandemic
at this point now they're literally just
giving people money
that's going to stop them from working
and it's funny because this is exactly
what they were saying last year when
there's a few republicans i think thomas
massey was one of them
they were like we shouldn't give people
more money than they could make working
because then no one will work
and the the response on the left this is
what i got to say man
anybody who comes to you and says you
just want poor people to suffer
tell them to shut up anybody arguing
that people shouldn't have to work
are not serious people they're just
trying to steal from you
that's it it's like someone in your
house and there's dishes everywhere and
you're like look we gotta do chores
no man you're just oppressing me i
shouldn't have to do any chores like
chores are dumb
no sorry man everyone's got to pitch in
to make sure the house is clean and make
sure things are being produced
you got a large faction of leftists who
are screaming i shouldn't have to work
we should not be listening to those
people those are those are kids those
are the children in the house screaming
like what do i have to do the dishes
because we're all working in this house
together to make the house function
the people who don't want to do any work
you know what you end up with you end up
with some some kids like
a 30 year old child living in a basement
just like really hairy and greasy and
just not doing any work and being like
shut up mom i don't want to work
stop stop stop giving these people
things they're not they're not serious
people well look
and and i will say that there are i'm
sure some people
and in fact there definitely are some
people in situations that are really uh
awful situations where it's hard for
them to work where they
you know for whatever reason but the
point to me is that
look economics are realities
and you can't just pretend that they're
not if they don't feel good
in the same sense that uh i'm sure most
people on the left would understand
like why is it that you want to
subsidize green energy
and you want to tax nicotine right or to
cigarettes because you know if you
subsidize something you're going to get
more of it
right if you tax something you're going
to get less of it that's just those are
just economic realities they don't have
emotions that's just the reality of the
situation just like
you know in some sense like the laws of
physics this is what you're going to get
so if you subsidize people not working
and then tax people for working
you are going to get less people working
uh
than you otherwise would and more people
not working so
we have to be adult enough to deal with
those realities
that if you're going to pay people to
not work regardless of what the
situation
is you're going to get a lot of people
who otherwise would work
now not work check this out check this
out we got the story from fox
mcdonald's drive-through customer spots
savage sign
telling people to be patient no one
wants to work
this is kind of incredible to see
someone at mcdonald's actually put up
because it's uh it's their photo there's
there's a video of it i can't play the
video
well actually i think i can but i'd
rather just read it so it's a tic tac
user named brittany logan spotted the
sign called it savage
it says we are short staffed please be
patient with the staff that did show up
no one wants to work anymore yeah man
the great elon musk if you don't make
stuff there's no stuff
yeah yeah but very controversial
simultaneously he supports ubi
sort of i've heard quotes
listen listen am i going to cry about
you know chemical garbage food not being
pumped out to the
to to poor people not really it is a
problem don't get me wrong
but part of me deep inside's like i just
i just want to gloat that mcdonald's
can't
you know keep cranking out this chemical
garbage food you know what i mean
yeah well i certainly understand that i
also do wonder
how much of a factor is the
is you know the fact that people have
been really i mean
like the psychological damage over the
last year is really something i mean
pretty much
everybody in the positions of authority
in this country
we're just working overtime to
terrify the american people about this
floating abstraction
of a germ that they have to live their
lives in constant fear
and always be inside and covering your
face and social distancing
and i'd imagine there are some people
that you mix that in with the economic
incentives of like
we'll pay you a little bit if you don't
work there's probably a lot of people
who are are like
really small well that it reinforces the
belief yeah but
i don't i honestly i don't know man i
think it's probably a lot of people
being like don't gotta work ain't gonna
work
you know there's a lot of that too like
look before any coveted stuff we saw the
green new deal and what did it say
that frequently asked questions put up
by uh aoc
are they willing or unable unwilling to
work they said they were going to
provide
what does it say or economic access to
those unwilling to work
unwilling it's like your parents go down
to the basement and they see you sitting
there and your own filth and like get a
job
no shut up mom aoc is like we should
help him and give him money
the best part of it was that they put it
up on her website in the in the
frequently asked questions
and then when people started making fun
of it they were like they were like
offended that you'd bring it up you're
like oh you're going to bring up that
old thing
it's from your website like what yes
we're going to ask you about it
so they said it was a first draft right
was it supposed to go up
there's a viral meme where somebody
tweeted it took a viral tweet
he this guy tweeted yo my job started
saying they were they were ending remote
working and people started quitting the
revolution is here
like there's actually a subreddit called
anti-work there are people who are like
i don't want to work
so the crazy thing is when you talk to a
lot of these leftists about this stuff
they say things like yeah but who would
want to work at mcdonald's you know
like is that a question of status or is
that a question of money because
you know i think a lot of mcdonald's
actually pay 15 bucks an hour the
problem is unemployment's paying more
than that
and so mcdonald's will have to increase
this this is why ubi makes no sense
here's what here's what where this
ultimately ends up what's happening now
with this unemployment policy
is just eroding the base of the economy
which will ultimately fall apart ubi
doesn't work you know why you ever watch
the hunger games
you see the hunger games yeah in the
capital in the hunger games they
were gluttons who would drink ipa cake
to barf to eat more food
didn't like did they uh they did
something like that in rome didn't they
like vomitoriums or something like that
after feasting the feathers and stuff
yeah they go barf and then eat more it's
not where the word come vomiting is not
where vomitorium comes from but i
that might be true or something like
that the point is in the hunger games
they have the districts who have to work
and you know the main character is in
the coal mining district
and the people in the capital don't do
work this is what these people truly
want
the leftists who are advocating for this
stuff want to live in the hunger games
but they want to be the capital
another example is how they want student
loan forgiveness
now i actually am for some form of
forgiveness maybe
forgiving interest rates yeah saying pay
back the principle of what you owe now
but we're not going to keep
raising the interest rates because
that's insane make it easy to pay off
but not free
how insane is it that the left right now
is advocating
for the working class people to pay off
the debts of the highest income earners
in the country
college people with college degrees have
higher salaries than than people who
don't
and they want the working-class people
to pay
off their debts that is the capital city
in the hunger games
now they're saying these these memes
where it's like if you can't afford to
pay someone more than they could make on
unemployment
then you are exploiting poverty bro
they're paying people 16
an hour to be unemployment like how much
like how long is that going on
so it's been going on for a year and
then biden's thing is going to extend it
okay so
the plan right now is with the new two
trillion dollar relief package is to
keep it going obama did that two
thousand eight nine something like that
but that was that was that was a
and i think it was an uh an extension on
standard unemployment yeah yeah it was
an extension to 99 weeks
back then um but the thing is like you
you see biden talking about just the
other day when he gave that speech
to the distanced masked congress uh and
he's talking about
uh taxing corporations and how they
don't pay their fair share and they have
all these tax loopholes and all this and
even forget the fact that joe biden's
been a senator for 85 years and he's
written all of these you know tax
loopholes into the law or at least
signed them into the law
that the truth is that he just signed
one of the biggest
if not the biggest corporate welfare
bills in history and to sign that into
history and be giving all of these money
to giant corporations
and then turn around and say ah you know
we really got to get some of this money
back is just
so disingenuous i mean like like stop
giving them money stop taxing and this
is the same thing you're saying with
bailing out student loan debts
stop taxing working people and
paying the well to do with the money
that you got
if we can't get that basic thing right
what are we talking about this is out
here this is why democrats want 16 year
olds to vote
because 16 year olds are going to be
sitting there and being like dude it's
like so dumb that they're homeless
people like we have houses just put the
homeless person in the house like who
are you dumb
and that's what they'll be voting for
right now you have these
20-something democratic socialist types
who are like the body administration
needs to be printing money and
increasing unemployment this is absurd
people are losing their jobs it's like
have you ever had a job well no but
that's not the point
and then it's like okay so what you're
saying is the government
should borrow tons of money print tons
of money devaluing the savings of the
working class
while all the businesses are shut down
so that people are forced to buy from
amazon
so basically they're devaluing the money
you have and then giving
what they've they've extracted from you
to amazon and walmart and
they're coming that's great that's a
great leftist policy today don't get me
wrong
these are the people that are coming out
right now cheering for facebook and
laughing about it
that is until they get censored and they
come begging for help saying please
we're the free speech warriors i got
censored
so how many states are open
um i i think for the most part like the
blue ones are
like somewhat opening so now it's
basically like
sort of a battle of the states in a
sense
oh dude we're we are uh we're being torn
a shreds
you look at i think i mentioned this a
while ago joe biden said
you know we're gonna have another
lockdown if we need it and i'm like
florida's already open for business
so who's joe biden talking to only the
blue states
yeah when he comes out and says you know
do x do y
lock things down and texas is like doing
the exact opposite you know he is not
speaking to a single person in texas
yeah i i've never seen anything like
this
in my life uh in our country and and
there's been
you know there's always examples of
where like the media has their
propaganda and real people don't really
believe it
but there's something about watching you
know um
the you know fouchy and the cdc
guidelines and you'll see on cnn and
they're like hey we've just decided
you can take your mask off outside and
you're literally like
looking out your window at kids just
playing with their masks off and
it really feels like something out of
the soviet union like the the
propaganda has come down from pravda and
you're looking and you're like
we've been doing this forever but what
are you talking about
and i know there are some people who
haven't i don't know what i mean like
local ordinances have already ended on
outdoor maps but that's my point
i mean who like even of liberal people
who kind of believe in the whole like
we're supposed to wear masks thing
who has been following all of the rules
since
are people still living like it's march
of 2020
a family member what i'm saying is they
actually
lifted the mandates in maryland for
instance and then
fauci's coming out later and i'm like
they already lifted the minutes
what are you talking about well that's
it and it's almost like they're going
like now we've given you our official
national orders that you can do the
thing
that you've been doing for 10 months but
so go ahead and do and it's
very bizarre and and and you see this
right like uh
in florida in texas people which both
states people are flooding into
people have been living relatively
normal lives
and and to pretend that we're just now
getting to the point where
outdoors you can take your mask off is
really there's such a disconnect i don't
i don't think
south dakota i've ever even had that
yeah outdoor mass mandates i'm not i
don't think so
uh taxes in florida completely opened up
but i bring up maryland specifically
because it's like
they got a republican governor but it is
a blue blue state
they lifted their outdoor mass mandates
a little while ago and now i see like
fauci coming out i'm like
who's he talking to california in new
york he's not talking to the rest of the
country
so isn't this the tenth amendment in
practice like okay from the example of
maryland i've never seen people outside
with masks period except the occasional
moronic runner who decides to wear his
mask while he's running but isn't this
the tenth amendment where states are
just deciding to do their own thing
because this was never delegated to the
federal government
well you know this is i mean it's a real
sick perversion of the 10th amendment if
it is that
because truthfully none of the states
have the right to do what they've done
i mean they don't have the 10th
amendment basically says that anything
that is not expressly delegated to the
federal government is left to the states
or the people
so that if something isn't uh you know
delegated
to a federal power the states can do it
but there is
no uh legality to the states violating
constitutionally protected rights in the
bill of rights so like
they're the uh cuomo and
you know newsom and all of these
governors yeah
they did not have the right to shut down
a religious ceremony to
tell you that you can't peacefully
assemble i mean they what we've
dealt with over the last year has been a
true
rise of many dictators amongst governors
who have taken
power to themselves that should be
crushed by
the federal or local governments or
anyone willing to do it and to me this
was the great failure of donald trump
2020 that he did not do anything to to
listen i mean if there's if if some uh
one
diner in alabama somewhere
put a whites only sign outside their
door and the state government didn't
want to do anything about it
the feds would come in there and say no
you cannot do that you don't have the
right to do that
and okay fine but the
cuomo and and you know newsom can just
shut down their entire states
and nobody's gonna come in and tell them
like sorry this is a free country
we have constitutionally protected
rights the the fact that that didn't
happen from anyone is is uh
unconscious when there were lawsuits
against the state for doing it
cuomo went okay i'll make another
executive order and then sue me for that
one
yeah and they just kept doing it that's
right you know so
you mentioned donald trump and he didn't
he he didn't handle this
you know uh let me slow down a second a
lot of people talk about the response to
kovitz specifically having to deal with
the spread
and they say trump didn't do a good
enough job and i say well let's be
honest
there's no control group by which to
measure whether he did or didn't do a
good job you can argue that some some
things in your opinion may have been
better honestly i don't know all that
much
so i think operation warp speed must
have been a good thing a lot of people
are really excited cheering on joe biden
for the vaccines that
donald trump helped make happen but
donald trump did not use the power of
the federal government
to protect people's constitutional
rights for a year
and you know what what did we see as
riots up across the country did donald
trump do anything about it no and people
were like
well hindsight is 20 20. you know now
that we know that he lost
people are saying at the time yeah but
they'll call him a fascist say here it
comes and then you know he's trying to
win in november it's like well he lost
anyway so he didn't stop any of the
extremists they went around burning
things down and
and smashing stuff and then we're all
left holding the bag with the biden
presidency who also is doing nothing and
it's only getting worse
yeah which uh i have a story on this
which brings me to my next story
this one's crazy man did you see this
video portland driver confronted by
armed group in broad daylight shocking
video shows you guys see this one oh no
portland there was a group of armed
leftists patrolling streets and blocking
roads
these aren't protesters holding hands
and pulling up banners literally this is
a guy with like a with like full
blackout gear and body armor
with an ar-15 and i think one other guy
and they're blocking cars smashing
windows and pepper spraying people
one guy gets up on you know he's like he
opens his door and he's standing up on
on
on his truck with the door open with his
hand on his hip and he draws his gun
he's holding it low ready
and the guys the antifa guys immediately
pull their guns are pointing their guns
at them
yelling them stop they're blocking the
road all right at some point
he gets out of his car and he actually
draws on one of these guys they tackle
him
take his weapon nothing at no no the
cops are alive is that purpose
the purpose is that far left the the far
left extremists are getting more
militant
and or were they protecting anything or
just arbitrary taking control
taking okay it's patrol it's not a
protest it is
when you march around with guns shutting
things down shutting down streets
smashing windows and attacking people i
mean maybe i shouldn't even we shouldn't
even call that a patrol we should call
it like an insurgency
attacking civilians in their cars no no
joke and there's another video right now
we can't show this i think it's out of
chicago i'm not sure was that chicago
that video that i sent you
which one oh i'm not sure there's uh uh
no context it might be new york it might
be chicago
there's uh a bunch of protesters in the
streets like they've been doing with
impunity
and a car just slams the gas when the
car starts pulling up we're seeing this
more and more and more
the far left will go around it start
banging on it yeah and it's like these
people are nuts
but because there's never been any real
legal
ramification they're not going to
southern keep doing it well this person
in the car said screw it slam the gas
and pete it's like it's a shocking video
normally when you see these videos where
they're like a car plows through
protesters it's like an suv going like a
mile an hour and they're screaming and
yelling and it just slowly drives away
nah this one was somebody hit the gas
and people went boom
that's what's gonna happen because you
see what happens in portland with this
with this video i don't i don't think
they have that fox news show so they
show a little bit i can't show too much
but we've got a tweet you can see here's
the guys wearing i it looks like it
might be body armor it might be actually
a tactical vest like a camelback or
something i don't know for sure
and they're holding they're holding uh
some ar-15s pointing at a regular
regular old guy
you know i thought i was going to
predict this but i said it was going to
be
far right locking down streets and
telling people to f off and get out of
their towns
that's probably stupid because we know
the far left has been increasing
it has been increasingly violent and the
escalation has come from them not
conservatives or
you know rural folk but so here we are
i gotta say i'm almost shocked um that
the
right wing response hasn't been more
ferocious and quicker
to be honest and i'm thankful for that
because i don't think it's gonna do any
good except just escalate the kind of
civil war which i think any sane person
would want to de-escalate
but um it's unbelievable
like the level to which this has
this has gotten and i think there's a
lot of you know like i'm
i'm i wonder what the
heck our society has done to allow some
of these young people who are out there
blocking cars
uh antagonizing people pushing windows
but but i'm not just blaming the people
doing that i mean obviously they're
wrong for doing that
but it's like how have we and this maybe
as i'm getting older
and that i have kids now i'm feeling
this way where i'm like how have we of a
society
failed these kids so much that this is
where we're at
and i think there's a lot to be said
there and then also i can't believe that
there's so much restraint on the other
side that there aren't more people just
plowing them down
the social pressure the social pressure
on social media you know they're
going through their feeds and they like
these campaigns that are going on i mean
i'm not on instagram but
like i you know there's all this
pressure do certain posts
and like it's insane yeah everybody
everybody make your your post
a blank screen onto your instagram to
show you're in line with and if you
don't
but look i'm just saying like you could
you can like
hate antifa and just talk about how
awful they are and i agree i'm not
saying you're wrong to do that i mean
these are like
punk kids who are being destructive and
just barbaric and it's awful
but you know if you zoom out a little
bit
you're like wow we really did like
create a society
where there are these kids where there's
like no
like there's no religion in our society
there's no value no that's replaced that
no discipline they're growing up in
single mother households they're
medicated from the time they're young
they're pushed into these universities
that don't prepare them for any type of
jobs and just saddle them with all of
this debt
they're just it's just there's nothing
you can never buy you know you come out
of
imagine being one of these young kids
who comes out of a university you've
been
fed this far left-wing propaganda uh
you're now a hundred grand in debt
um what prospects do you ever have to
like get married have kids and take care
of a family
you could never afford a house you're
going to go work at starbucks and try to
pay your home they feel like this is
their value
it is their value system no that's why
it's a cult the problem is
not much of what you what you said but
also consider that these are people
growing up
in the wealthiest conditions in human
history i'm not denying that right so
you're right
but look in the 1700s even if you were
wealthy you still
understood some hardship the the old
saying is that
you a poor person today has better
dental care than rockefeller did the
1900s because technology improved things
so if you were a rich person in 1700s
you still need to understand some basic
things and so the gap
between you and the poor while what may
have been dramatic for the time
is insanely different from today so
you're you're absolutely right they're
wealthier than kings were at a certain
point in time right but there's
so what i'm talking about is something
separate from wealth what i'm talking
about is look my
grandfather was far poorer than any of
us are today and
and suffered through more hardships than
any of us could imagine i mean
he was a jew who escaped nazi germany
and then fought in world war
ii i mean just a very hard life and
worked in a factory that's all he ever
did for his life but with that job
he could he got married his wife my
grandmother didn't work
he took care of two kids owned a house
owned two cars played poker on the
weekends like you could
you could take care of a a wife
and kids and have an identity and a life
whereas today even though they're much
richer than that what is your chances of
owning a home getting married paying for
the cost of education
i'm saying there's no identity there is
my point you're you're
you're right on the surface but you got
to compare the life
of a family in the 40s and 50s to the
life of a family today
we have television we have internet
we've got some of the greatest
technology ever created and we have to
pay for those things that requires labor
as the population expands we get more
specialists and more access to better
technology
we still have to pay for it all right so
sure you know my dad
he was able to you know he actually
worked two jobs when i was younger
and his dad before him worked a single
job you know the greatest generation but
what did they have in their home
many of them didn't have tvs and so the
kids would do chores would would go on
you know
on uh paper newspaper routes and they
would be doing some kind of work
so what's happening is we're saying
today you know these kids can't even own
a house yes you can
it's called in the middle of west
virginia and it's a 30 000 house
you just don't want to live in it so
sure there were suburban living when
people didn't have the same access to
utilities when people didn't have access
to the same medication
people today say oh it's we need
universal health care because people
can't go to the doctor dude
the medical care you can get on debt is
a hundred times better than medical care
they were getting a hundred years ago
or a couple hundred years ago when they
were injecting people with mercury or
whatever for
for syphilis nothing is stopping a
person from taking their family
and going and building a cab in the
middle of the woods except
i guess for the fear eventually the
federal government will wander off into
the middle of wyoming and we'll be mad
at you about it so
so i i don't completely disagree with
you i think that the fact that we've
become richer than ever before is a good
thing and i think the fact that we have
luxury goods and consumer goods for
cheaper than ever before i think it's
great i mean it's risen the standard of
living
i guess it's just the fact that we've
also in this process
created through our elected politicians
this system where we've subsidized the
cost of housing
subsidized the cost of education
subsidize the cost of health care to the
point that they've all been tremendously
inflated
and we've also just lost a sense of
community and
values which i think also goes hand in
hand with the
the government taking more and more of a
participatory
role in society and i think this is just
again i'm not disagreeing with you it's
just a cocktail that's worked out to be
what we see now we need uh people need
to to have a
a return to like normalcy and
understanding of the world what that
means is
imagine life if you were just one day
woke up in the middle of the woods bug
naked
congratulations that's life everything
we've built i'm sorry i shouldn't even
say we
everything ev every shoulder that is
being stood upon by the giants
is done for us we woke up i was in new
york one day
and i was riding my bike over the
williamsburg bridge and i was like
wow i never did anything to deserve this
bridge
to ride up and over this river and i had
to i just imagine i'm like what it must
have been like a couple of years ago
when people were like waiting for the
ferry they had to pay for to do it and
then some people said
i am going to plant this tree whose
shade i know i will never sit beneath
because in 50 years the children will be
able to and their lives will be better
today people are now demanding and
entitled of all of these things that
were gifted to us that we
never paid for and so what happens is
they say i should be able to have
a massive house five bedrooms i should
be able to only have to work
you know certain amount of time
throughout the week so i can have every
luxury
that this life can afford me and it's
like nah
you're spoiled i'm sorry but it's true
if you had to go crash land on an island
somewhere
and then build a house out of coconuts
or whatever that's life
yeah we are living a gifted life you
know people came before us yeah you're
so right and you know what's interesting
about that is that
like kind of what you're getting at is
that this idea of like the philosophical
idea of ubi
right like we kind of already have that
i mean like just in
in just a pure free market with no
government giving you a ubi
you kind of already have this where just
for the
because we were born here in a first
world country in 2021 and we're living
we and we do stand on the shoulders of
all of these people i mean
we none of us really earned all of this
technology that
we get to speak through i mean you may
have bought the microphones and stuff
but we didn't invent all of it and we
whether we have all these things like
you were saying with the bridge and the
trees that other people have you know
molded it before us the bridge is a
better example than the microphones
because that's something you can just
use that paying for well sure but i'm
just saying that even if you pay for
this someone else invented it and we all
benefit from the fact that other minds
put in all of this labor to make all of
this happen
and just the fact that we have this
level of wealth around us i mean we
could be the exact same people
born in some third world country or on
some desert island and we don't get any
of that
so that is our ubi but to your other
point about that
which i think is the real it's almost
like the the contradiction
of the human experience is that even
though there's this kind of selfish
impulse to go well no we don't care
about passing it on to the next
generation
and you go like well look all of this
was passed on to you
so don't you have some obligation to
pass it on to the next generation but
i'll tell you this
after having kids it really you know
opened my eyes up to this that
there's it's actually a much more
rewarding existence you will be a much
happier person
when you are focused on passing
something on to the next generation
that's like the
beauty of life that when you're living
for others and thinking about what's
been given to you and what you can give
on to the next generation
that's when you don't want to go block a
car in the street and throw a molotov
cocktail
through the window because you've got
something kind of bigger to live for
they don't have kids well that's that's
what i'm saying and so so
you can be a person of empathy and
community without having kids
sure if you if you if you uh you know so
we as a society
but it helps it absolutely throws it in
your face but so you have people
who don't have family don't have
community
they they create these nebulous online
communities of disparate beliefs that
make no sense
and then they're angry that they're not
getting what they think they deserve
they're not working
they don't want to work they want to
make the government pay for it extract
the wealth out of the system to give to
them
and they will get violent this is
it is what's the right way to describe
it it is um blasphemy
no no no it's it's a chaotic destructive
force
like fire jealousy that is burning at
the foundation it's a rot
at the foundation of our society of
people who think they're entitled to
things but won't work for things what's
happening and it's corrupting the
foundations
and if we don't do something about it
which should be associated they think
they're
helping by not having kids that's what
their argument is because they think you
know we're overpopulated i don't think
a lot there's a lot of people i think
but that's a rationalization i think
yeah exactly so what i think is actually
happening is
they're extremely selfish they want
everyone to give to them
they don't understand what it means to
give back and so
as you mentioned it's a rationalization
oh well i'm doing this because
you know bad for the planet okay you
know
i think a lot of it is wealth disparity
because we are super wealthy all of us
but the disparity is greater than it's
ever been and if you've ever been poor
in a room with a bunch of rich people
and like you're having a great day
everyone's having a great time you're
all equals then all of a sudden you're
like i gotta go do some crap job i hate
and they're all like i don't because i
my dad was rich and i i don't ever have
to do anything and
the anger that you feel well i i i i i
don't know jealousy it's almost
irrational anger you felt that
yeah i've never felt that yeah i felt
like why do i have to be the one that
has to go work a low-paying job because
my parents weren't rich
when i my friends don't have to worry
that's probably the end and they're
driving around in cars
exactly and and exactly because i didn't
have that so
i grew up uh uh someone mentioned
earlier take a shot of tim
mentioned south side of chicago now's
your chance you just did
uh and so a lot of a lot of crackheads a
lot of heroin addicts a lot of poor
people
and then i started you know playing
music which you know
i went around to different uh venues met
different people in different areas
eventually met a bunch of rich kids and
i never cared
i don't i don't care i don't care about
what that person is doing
it's it's a waste of my time to sit
there and be like why do they have money
i was like their parents are rich
whatever
i'm gonna focus on doing my thing but
you know what maybe i'm lucky enough to
have
to be grounded in reality to understand
something really simple
anybody listening here's what you do if
you're in a big city
even today stand in a street corner and
say cheeseburger
and look people that's a cheeseburger
cheeseburger eventually someone will
come back and back i got your
cheeseburger buddy
i'm not kidding it will work i i'm dead
serious
you can go to any major city because
people
tend to be good and want to help yeah
and you can say
to any random person help me buy
cheeseburger but but hold on
you're right go go go to sub-saharan
africa
go to the middle east go to egypt and
see what happens if you sit there and
beg for this stuff
people are going to be like is that is
that a joke yeah sometimes a lot of
countries
i think sure the essence of the point
you're making which is is absolutely
right is that our
our crisis is not a true crisis of
real poverty that's not the issue
exactly like even our poor people
are rich people homeless compared to
other societies that have existed so
that's not the problem and again
maybe this is just like the way i look
at things
since being a father but when i look at
somebody
who's out on the streets like one of
these antifa members
who's this little punk kid who's dressed
in all blacks some of them who will be
bro
well okay fine but he's still a punk kid
in his 40s
who will you know like you know the way
they fight where it's not even like
someone
like like there's no honor in even being
like like why don't we take this outside
and fight
it's like they'll go talk [ __ ] and then
someone stands up to them and they run
away and then they look at the other guy
and then they sucker punch him behind
them and then they all pound on him when
he's down
i go i look at that and go who raised
you
nobody like who and and what what what
was your who were your parents who were
responsible for instilling
something into you the federal reserve
well well that's part of it
but it's there were real human beings
who made this human being
and i'm just saying that we lost it's
not an issue of poverty
it's something different than that it's
it's it's like the soul of the culture
like we lost this thing that honor
yes honor and some type of social
pressure
to raise your damn children so i was
i was i was thinking about this the
other day
scruples are gone people people used to
genuinely feel remorse
if they if they you know stole or or
or lied to somebody it's it's great
maybe i'm romanticizing the past
but community used to be like i can't do
that why well because you can't do it
you know it's just like deep within your
soul you feel something you can't do
scruples
now it's like people are like oh i'll
lie to whoever get whatever i want
the moral foundation is being shattered
did you see uh i saw someone was sharing
this
clip like an old alex jones clip on
twitter today where he's you know
it's like a classic alex jones clip
where he's screaming like a maniac but
if you listen to what he's saying he's
actually making a pretty good point
was like 90 of alex jones you're like
man if you were just not yelling at me
i'd agree because you were playing the
frogs again
it was old it was like it must have been
like 15 years old but he's talking about
how he's like the kids are worshiping
justin bieber
and they're worshiping you know imagine
and he goes what about magellan
magellan's excelled around the world and
he's like that is amazing
he's screaming at you but you're kind of
like i mean he's making a good he was
my favorite he's like there were 200 men
on that ship and only 11 made it
dude if you weren't pulling your hair
out of your head like i'd say you're
making a very logical point wait but
that's there's part of this right like
there there was
no tradition and honor and like
upbringing for for children and i'm just
saying that i think
a lot of times today at least i get this
a lot that if you if you address any of
these issues
people say they they go oh you're like
some social conservative right winger or
something like this and
and then the implication is almost one
step away from like well you must hate
gay people or hate trans people or hate
black people or something like that
but we're not allowed to ever just go
and i feel this a lot more these days
but you just go like you know you go on
instagram and see all the like you know
every girl's like in a thong and
everything
you're like these values suck this sucks
as a culture to raise a daughter in like
it's not this is not
good before we move too far i have to
make one point
uh on your alex jones thing you remember
when he was talking about
turning the frogs gay that's like
probably the most famous alex jones meme
he's yelling and he's like they're
turning the freaking frog he like you
know pounds
imagine if instead of that you had alex
but no one had ever seen him before
right it's the first time he's ever
appeared
he's wearing a you know like a a tweed
sweater or something or whatever
he's got like leather patches and he's
got a corn cob pipe he's wearing glasses
and he goes
now an interesting study came out about
atrazine it's a pesticide and he's
talking to
other you know glasses individuals he
goes the the interesting thing about
this atrocity is that it's disrupting
the endocrine systems of of amphibians
notably frogs
in in many of these regions now on the
coasts you can see that it's draining
off into the oceans having less of an
impact on groundwater but in the middle
east it's a very serious problem
dare i say jokingly they're turning the
frogs gay now
no no but in all seriousness is it there
would never be a meme
it was alex jones yelling and slamming
they're turning the frog
that's the trump phenomenon right like
when everyone everyone would be like man
if he just didn't if he wasn't so brash
and he didn't do all this
then maybe he could have gotten this
done and you're like no he'd never be
there
right that's the whole thing right yeah
it's that's the contradiction is he'd
never be there if he hadn't
the reason trump was president is
because he was the guy
who was willing to look at jeb bush and
go your brother
lied us into war and basically wink wink
nod nod you can't pleasure your wife was
basically the measure
that was basically what i mean what do
you think low energy was
really saying when he kept telling he
kept going jeb bush your low energy what
was it like what was the real
implication of that yeah but he wasn't
wrong and then no he clapped
he clearly wasn't that's why he won
because he was clearly dead right and
then even he could look at hillary
clinton and go yeah and
nasty woman and all these things and
that's part of why he won
but it was also his downfall you know
and that so that's that's the thing with
alex jones right
but there is something there's a really
important principle there and
from my perspective and maybe this is my
own libertarian bias
but i really do think that the
government
the rise of the welfare state the rise
of big government uh
big government in america that they
undermined
the all the bonds that used to hold
people together right so instead of the
welfare state you would have
communities you would have churches you
would have neighborhoods all of these
bonds and that as the state got more and
more powerful they destroyed all of
these bonds
intentionally in the same way that the
communists hate religion because they
hate anything that's that's a
a unifying force more powerful than the
state
so to me this is what destroyed our
culture i've been i've been talking
about abolishing the police now for the
past
i guess a couple of months but and
michael malus has been cheering for it
on twitter
but it's not for the same reason for the
most part
you know so so michael said when we had
alex jones on the show
he said that it's his constitutional
right to keep a bear arm to defend
himself
and every single cop in new york city
would arrest him if he tried to uphold
his own rights and that's why he said
every single cop was was bad
and alex was like no you can't say that
that's wrong and only michael malus can
make alex jones the moderate
right right right and that's but so so
i'm actually i actually do think we need
police the problem is we
they shouldn't be following uh in
unconstitutional orders
enforcing illegal laws or taking illegal
action but now the main reason
because i've had people message me
saying tim you're wrong about abolishing
the police well hold on
have you been paying attention to what's
going on what story did we just cover
just in
the preview in the last segment portland
antifa
in blackout gear which they've been
doing the whole time now with rifles
stopping vehicles smashing out their
windows attacking pedestrians and
regular folk
and when a guy tries to get through and
draws on them because they drew on him
already
they knock him down to take his gun
where the cops the cops can't stop
antifa
in portland the more the majority of
people who were arrested even on felony
charges
even people who confessed to attacking
cops had their charges dropped
but guess what the fbi is hunting down
each and every single conservative
in new york city when the proud boys
fought antifa those proud boys are now
in prison the system is broken
it's corrupted we are watching all of
this happen every day
and the cops may be neutral arbiters but
it's a sorting algorithm
where they are they are funneling people
on left and right into a justice system
that is only
punishing the right and moderates and
those who are standing up for small
businesses
i i assure you if you live in the
portland area
and these these groups with guns come
out if you even try to defend yourself
you will get locked up we've already
seen it happen one guy
who drew on these black lives matter
protesters he got charged i think
he got a felony or something he had a
felony charge and he was
legally bearing his arm which is allowed
to do and there was a group
a raucous group which is known to have
been violent in protest
and he drew on them you could argue the
whole thing all day and night but a
felony charge
so here's what's going to happen
conservatives have consistently defended
the cops and i understand why
because cops do a tough job but then we
started seeing cops
shut down small businesses arrest small
business owners and then conservatives
aren't saying
nah i'm done with this and throwing the
thin blue line flag in the dirt and
stomping on it
now it's starting to come back to
defending cops again and i'm like do you
realize
you're the target in new york city it's
like what 20
conservative it's like very very few
conservatives
when antifa goes around smashing up
windows these people aren't going to go
to jail
when you go and in any way defend
yourself or defy these restrictions
they will lock you up in two seconds it
was the funniest thing when that salon
owner
in in texas i think it was she got
arrested for opening her salon
while they were letting the criminals
out of the jail they were saying we
can't have criminals in jail because of
covet
but she can and they they were saying it
was uh dangerous for covid to
open your salon but we will take you and
put you in jail where there's this
massive covet outbreak
absolutely letting people out but and
that's that's inhumane to put someone
into a
situation yeah well i mean it's inhumane
to put a human being in a cage for the
crime of opening their business period
but
particularly in a patent while letting
the criminals out have you heard the
term anarcho-tyranny
before because that's what this is
describing so the idea of
anarcho-tyranny
is the idea that you have the worst of
both worlds right right you have the
worst of anarchism and the worst of
tyranny so
there are incredibly rigid rules that
you will be
just destroyed for violating i mean if
you get something wrong on your tax form
you will go you know to jail for this if
you do what you know there's all of
these different laws
that you can be busted for for any
different number of
felonies that you don't even know about
like we all commit like five felonies a
day without even knowing it right
but then at the same sense there's the
worst sense of anarchy
for people so you get your car stolen
and a cop comes up to you and goes well
that sure does suck i can fill out a
form and then we'll see you later
but if you defend yourself with you know
a weapon then you're gonna go to jail
and that's what we're seeing more and
more right
we're seeing the fact that this has been
going on in san francisco and los
angeles and all these places where
if someone comes in and steals from your
store we're not really going to
prosecute them
but if you pull a gun on them while
they're stealing from their store you
might go to jail for a decade so this is
the
this is the world that we're living in
more and more now and i think that
conservatives are
starting to realize that they are the
enemy
group so for you for you to be defending
the enforcers of the state which let's
get real that's what cops are
for you to be defending them when you're
the enemy group
is uh to borrow a word that some on the
right
like to use the ultimate in cockatry
we're at a point now where we're
we've been watching this for a year the
salon owner
they they open the jails and release the
criminals
and then put the small business owner in
the jail i mean that's that's tyranny so
i made that point
if this continues conservatives will be
less less able to vote because
they're being charged with felonies not
even conservatives like moderates who
defend themselves are going to get
felony charges
can't vote sorry in many states i mean
the left might actually give them their
right to vote back
in a long enough period of time it will
just detriment the right
and it will scare everyone into being
clearly we don't want to be with
whatever that is i'll just do what the
left says
but hold on what if at this point we
said alright how about this no cops
then what happens well you can keep and
bear arms now
you can defend yourself and you can
defend yourself
oh this would be cleaned up in a second
believe me all these riots you don't
need trump to send in the federal goons
or anything like that
if you just said all it takes and there
were a couple like local sheriffs who
did this during the riots and basically
cleaned up their whole
town yeah if you just said hey guess
what we believe
in the second amendment here and if you
go and
and if there was actually the the state
behind you on this and you said
if you go and violate someone's uh
private property
and they have a gun we are not
prosecuting them for defending
themselves
this thing would be cleaned up but by
the way can i just make one more point
to what you were saying before
what were the few exceptions for the
people who were actually prosecuted
uh during all these governments the
government buildings that were that were
attacked right
so what is the clear message from the
government there how disgusting is this
stay away from our property you go ahead
and you vandalize any of the private
property you want to
you go terrorize a shoe store owner go
terrorize a bodega
no problem you stay away from the state
house and you'll be just
conservatives got to get on board with
abolishing the police and not
every single instance small towns are
probably fine
but uh the best example is in milwaukee
when black lives matter i think was
milwaukee they showed up to a guy's
house right
they were protesting in front of his
house one of the guys who organized this
had previously been to another mob
gathering that set fire to someone's
home
so all these people are outside
screaming this guy pulls up his shotgun
and points it out the window
the window's closed when he points it
you know visibly at the window when the
police show up
black lives matter is clapping and
cheering and celebrating as the cops go
into this man's home and arrest him
well for what now maybe he should have
pointed the gun directly at them
but like i said these one the guy who
organized this had previously organized
another rally where they set fire to a
woman's home
they said they twice cops came out put
it out they set fire to it again
so this guy's like i'm gonna show them
i'm armed and you can make an argument
whether he should or shouldn't have done
that
i believe people have a right to keep
and bear arms and if you're on your
property and people are encroaching on
your property and threatening you
it was he didn't even fire a shot it was
a warning but here's the point
the cops gleefully arrested him
the worst point black lives matter
celebrated that means
you think people have been saying they
want they want to abolish the police
they can federalize it they want to
abolish police to get their woken forces
and
they don't really want to abolish the
police they want to exert pressure until
the police start doing whatever they
want out of fear of losing their jobs
yeah well why do you think they did such
a 180 on abolish the police
i mean as soon as the implications of
that started coming out they were like
well abolish the police doesn't really
mean abolishing that or defund the
people that's the democrats
no what i mean is the left comes out and
says abolish the police and the cop goes
i don't want to lose my job well then
you better arrest the conservative you
got it anything you say please i'm so
i'm begging you please
well look i mean if you're somebody
who's if you
are a right-winger or a conservative
just
think through the implications of
actually defunding the police and what
that would mean
well it's like like you said well
there's nobody's going to arrest you for
any type of gun violation so gun rights
are now absolute
they're not going to be able to enforce
these like stupid regulations on your
business who's going to be the tax
collectors who's going to do all of this
it actually leads to a much smaller
government
world which would be a much better
situation
and take personal response and also i
will say this too it also uh
takes away what are some of the
legitimate criticisms of people on the
left which i'm not saying is like the
violent rioters but there are some
people on the left who make a legitimate
point that there are cops
who go around and harass people in the
these high crime neighborhoods
now i'm not saying that there aren't
legitimate criminals in those
neighborhoods who deserve to be harassed
but there's also let's get real there's
a lot of kids who walk around who just
look like the suspect that they're
trying to go after in these
neighborhoods who get harassed
and let them also let them also not be
harassed anymore
also but you know the whole war on guns
like the whole all the whole gun control
regime i mean the real
victims of it not saying it's the
exclusive victims
but the the most likely victims of it
are people who live in these high crime
neighborhoods who are minorities for the
most part
who are who have guns usually to protect
themselves and they get charged and they
get changed
we got guys we we have uh tons of people
in this country
disproportionately black and brown
people who are sitting in cages for
decades for the crime of owning
a gun not doing anything to anyone with
that gun
just having a gun the prohibition on
guns has been just as disastrous as the
prohibition on drugs and we should end
all of them i think the party of
personal responsibility should start
taking more of it
because you know look i get it maybe
there's this vision of like an old timey
era when
officer friendly was there to protect
your community now we're at a point
where
the justice system is basically
corrupted
extremely wealthy leftists started
funding district attorneys races putting
in far-left da's people like kim fox
after jesse smallett's whole ridiculous
you know maga country garbage kim fox
lets him go
this guy it was so obvious this is what
happens the justice system is
completely corrupt but i gotta stress
man the proud boys in new york city
four years in prison yeah if the proud
boys want to get in a fight with antifa
because anthony has been threatening and
harassing them
then maybe you don't want police to be
there to arrest you and put you in
prison afterwards
when you decide that you are going to
confront the problem in the way you
think is is appropriate
now look i don't think fighting is
appropriate i don't think anybody should
be fighting antifa or the proud boys
but if antifa wants to show up to
someone's event and instigate fights
okay then there's a thing called mutual
combat okay maybe that's what we need
the problem is
in new york you can't have guns you
can't protect yourself if you if you
even
consider it they will lock you up the
problem is that
the way i described it recently is
imagine you're at a blackjack table at a
casino
and it's it's a right-wing guy and the
left-wing guy
the left-wing guy is counting cards and
you're sitting there going like he keeps
winning
he's winning like he's look how much
money he's got i keep losing
because the house always wins the the
dealer isn't playing favorites
it's just that they're gaming the system
and the house is gaming you
that's where we're currently at with
conservatives defending cops
it's good they're going to keep going
after small businesses antifa is going
to
walk around the street with rifles now
hold on they're allowed to do that
you can walk around with a gun
constitutional right keep and bear arms
but they smash out windows they attack
pedestrians and then draw down on some
dude
who's driving his truck through the area
guess when no charges guess when
police first started in america it was
the uh
late 1600s early 1700s yeah 1636 so it
was like
night watch groups that would report to
like a constable
well it was initially we had local
militias some states i think there were
like two states
set up slave patrols from that the left
has tried arguing that the origin of all
police was slave patrols
the idea of centralized law enforcement
was actually imported from some european
countries i think was like amsterdam or
something
and so eventually people started saying
maybe instead of having these ever
escalating conflicts between neighbors
and the militia
we just create neutral arbiters who will
come down make the arrest and the courts
can deal with it
we're at a point now where that that i
think that's a great idea
however in these blue states people
don't care about your rights and believe
they have a right to vote away your
rights
so they'll say like i don't care the
second amendment says i think we can
just decree your right doesn't exist
the constitution was supposed to stop
that apparently it doesn't now you have
conservatives who live in these places
who are surrounded by cops who would
gladly enforce
illegal actions like bill de blasio's
ridiculous painting or
arrest you for exercising your god-given
rights
the state doesn't give them to you the
government doesn't god did that's in the
constitution
the thing that's so infuriating to me is
that we've
watched um let's just say just in the
21st century not going back you know the
whole history of policing but just in
the 21st century
i mean the we have the most militarized
police force in the world i mean
well i'm just saying there's really
nothing like there's really no country
out there that has as many swat
units has as much military gear and
their police officers
when i say this i mean but is that
because we're a big country
i don't think that's a fair thing no i
mean i think even per capita even
our department of education has a swat
team the epa
has a swat team i mean we have like we
have a police force
look it up i promise you we have a
police force that's just unlike anything
else the nypd i think is in the top
20 biggest armies in the world like it's
not just that we're a big
country i mean there's a lot more to it
than that and a lot of it is right
the department of education as a swat
team oh yeah no the department of
education
all right you got me there that's a
weird one so i'm saying like and we have
all of this
and if it was ever justified you'd be
like well when there's mass
riots this militarized police will make
sure to stop it and then when there are
the mass riots
they do nothing and then i mean what is
i think we have 50
000 swat raids on average a year or
something like that i mean it's
something crazy and you'll have
swat raids over like
alleged drug possession sometimes they
get the wrong house and just shoot your
dog or whatever they've shot kids before
it's like swat ray you know if you were
to think about it in theory and we were
just talking about it like when is it
appropriate
to have a swat raid you'd probably be
like i don't know like a hostage
situation
when someone's about to kill someone
else maybe not it's like i think he's
got a no-no plant in his drawer and they
so we have this this is what i mean by
the anarcho tyranny
we have the worst to go after the former
president's
lawyer right right exactly or roger
stone or something like that so we have
the worst of a police state
without any of even the benefits of it
like they'll protect your property if
there's a riot
so i mean you know do you remember the
story there's some guy i can't remember
exactly what it was so maybe i'm getting
a little bit wrong factor me on this one
he put grow lamps in a house he like
rented a house he put grow lamps in it
with
like ficus or some stupid house plant
and then he
set up cameras and just waited and then
a swat team raided the house
and he was like what are you doing in my
like what's going on they jump out with
cameras they're filming all the cops and
they're like what are you doing
and they apparently tried using grow
lamps as justification that they were
doing a drug raid
wow because they they were detecting the
energy consumption yeah they could see
the energy consumption and so they made
an assumption about what's going on in
the house
and i bet you none of those cops went to
jail no but the guy like put on the
internet and he was like
sure but you know if we had any type of
like just society going here wouldn't
you be like well okay
i mean you just committed a crime right
you broke into somebody's house
any of us would go to jail if we did
that but they don't so and and the other
thing that i got to say
is that you know i understand and i
agree with a lot of what you're saying
like and and
there is like a lot of these left-wing
uh um
you know cities and states do have these
problems but i gotta say i find
something
not maybe kind of funny in a dark way
but certainly ironic
that now joe biden is turning the war on
terror
inward and the target is right wingers
and even liz
cheney is like championing this and i
guess i'm just
old enough to remember that it was the
right wingers
who supported george w bush who
championed this whole war on twitter
these are not the same and mocked out
there's a lot of one of them
no no i'm not just talking he's a
democrat now i'm not an arms dealer
the republican party is not on board
with that let's change i'm not
i'm not talking about just the
republican party or the ones who went
over to the democratic party
i'm saying that right wingers in america
voted for dick cheney and george w
bush and they mocked i'm not saying all
of them but a large enough percentage of
them
boxed 20 years ago so you're right
now the chickens have come home to roost
no you know you're talking about 38 year
olds
who didn't vote for that who are now
finding themselves conservatives or
republican beings they are
that's right they are paying for the
sins of the right wingers who came
before absolutely
who who you know
i don't care if it's democrat republican
we're paying for the penalties of their
failures
going back so much of the problems with
this country and don't get me wrong i
think you can go back to woodrow wilson
and pretty much blame everything on him
but all of it i mean yes and i believe
that
all woodrow wilson's fault he was real
all woodrow wilson's fault
the federal reserve yes he created the
federal reserve the income tax got us
into world war one
basically created the fbi as we know it
it's all his fault
but if you want to focus on the 21st
century
the first eight years of it were under
george w bush and dick cheney
and they blew the entire beginning of
this century
oh yeah and they really and and we are
really suffering under those
ramifications now
and so there's it is just like now it's
taken on this new
kind of woke flavor but many times it's
the same corporate interests
the same military-industrial complex
interests behind it
it's just the new justification is
woke-ism like now we have to stay in
afghanistan for feminism or something
you know it's not
it's not because we have to hunt down
bin laden anymore but it's the same
policy
and the same companies profiting and
like kind of all the same thing
but i'm just saying i remember when the
right wing had the culture and
they kind of did set us on this course
the establishment lost control with
trump
the democrats were able to ward to to to
keep bernie sanders out
to co-opt him and you know make him just
shuffle the the leftists into the
democratic coalition
but on the right trump was the raging
bull and they couldn't control they lost
control
so these establishment concerns
republican i don't call them
conservatives and neocons
become democrats effectively they start
supporting the democrats do now you have
people like kinzinger and liz cheney
who want the war on terror to focus on
the deviant right-wing americans yes
that's right they this what they want is
the neoconservative right to be the
right in this country and the neolib to
be the left in this country
bernie sanders was weak and they easily
shut him down
and but trump wasn't and they couldn't
turning the war on terror against him
you're right and i think you're really
on to something there and as you could
see if you remember
when bernie sanders looked like he might
beat joe biden if you remember before
super tuesday when
they all circled the wagons it got him
out what did you hear from the corporate
press
they are like the brown shirts they're
basically nazis now
imagine that if they had actually won
and gotten their candidate in there you
would see a lot of this energy turned on
them what the
right wingers are being punished for
right now is that they committed
blasphemy
you were told to vote for jeb bush we
told you we were giving you another
they really wanted and you decided you
decided to go for this trump guy
who we told you was unacceptable and so
now you have to be smacked as nazis and
the same they were starting to do the
same thing but the democrats kind of
fell in line and also bernie sanders
fell in line so their leader
basically fell they were saying the
bernie bros are violent yeah it's
dangerous
sexist remember when bernie came out and
was like stop doing these things
like he had he had to tell his followers
to stop being violent which was all
[ __ ]
so you think we would have avoided a lot
of this extreme polarization if it had
been
obama jeb bush and then like a nice
back and forth no my point is that we
have this extreme polarization because
of bush and obama and all of them but
now the establishment is freaking out
because they they've lost control of
this thing
i think that trump you know the standard
line is that like
trump destroyed the republican party but
i think that's nonsense i think that
george w
bush destroyed the republican party and
and trump was the aftermath and now they
love his paintings
well that's right they do but because
they always loved him they never had a
problem with him
look they hated him everyone hated him
they turned on him when it was
convenient they sold his wars
they the new york times was not being
woke left as judith miller and
all of these hacks were selling every
one of his lies which were ridiculous
okay the idea that saddam hussein
and iran and north korea were all doing
9 11 together or whatever it was
they sold these wars got us into them
then when they saw the disastrous
ramifications of the wars
they went yeah yeah yeah he's real bad
this is no good then they pushed behind
obama but this was
all what did obama do expanded every
last one of them and what did joe biden
do once he was put in charge of iraq
little little brother got control of the
the construction contracts
he made millions of dollars just no
coincidence mind you
and then you know for just totally
unrelated reasons his son got on the
board of ukrainian energy firm
during you know the height of this
conflict with with natural gas and gas
problem it's just
totally coincidental and obama not only
continued
the bush foreign policy he expanded it
to a level that
bush and cheney probably couldn't have
gotten away with i mean obama inherited
the war in iraq and afghanistan and
continued them for every single day of
his
uh presidency but not only that he
expanded the war into libya
syria yemen somalia i mean he just took
the wars
all over the place the war on
whistleblowers well well yes
more whistleblowers prosecutors
prosecuted than all other presidents
combined yeah it might as well be the
espionage it might as well have been
another eight years of george w
bush maybe yeah maybe even worse i mean
because
and the press was behind him all the way
i mean the activists hated george w bush
but like you mentioned the new york
times sold it but i think that there was
something that they noticed with obama
um and i think this is where the
corporate woke takeover really
started is that obama um one of the most
effective
things from the establishment point of
view and one of the most awful things
from
any sane person's point of view that
obama did was obama really destroyed the
anti-war left
and there was a really strong anti-war
left under george w
bush that is easy to forgive protest i
mean yeah
i mean you're talking hundreds of
thousands of people in the streets like
on the level of like the women's march
or something like that was like like
that was the type of energy and it
wasn't just focused at some stupid thing
it was really focused it like we were
lied into war
repeal the patriot act you know things
that really matter
uh the patriot act ultimately what part
of what brought donald trump you know to
his knees and his presidency
again ironically um but so they were
focused on that but what happened when
obama came in
it all went away and and i really think
that a big part of this was that
the the liberal and left i'm talking
like the whole left half of the country
you know like
liberals and left all you know so much
of their identity
was about not being racist
and and in the best sense of that term
you know like not
you know not like this woke craziness of
today but the fact that we go look man
black people were treated horribly from
the beginning of this country and we're
against racism and jim crow and racism
you know all this stuff and when you had
the first black
president who was also this charismatic
guy who they wanted to love
to be against him was just very hard for
a lot of liberals and left-wing people
to do
so it just kind of silenced them
hey bill remember when we put on that
event called ending
violence racism and authoritarianism
headlined by daryl davis
one of the most famous radicals and
antifa threatened to burn the theater
down if we had those conversations well
yeah there you go
you can't allow that but but what
happened right was that
after that and then into the occupy
movement and what i think what
my theory on it more or less is that a
lot of very powerful
interests started noticing that there
was this kind of
woke impulse and of course all the
theory was in the background there was
critical race theory and all this stuff
in the background
and they started noticing that this
could really tear apart the unity on the
left
and then on the heels of occupy wall
street when
as you've noticed it started tearing it
apart on its own organically
like the woke stuff started taking over
and people were like oh you're not even
focusing on the 99
anymore now you're focusing on like what
divides us and then all of a sudden you
see
i mean if you've looked at any of those
nexus charts new york times mentions of
racism
washington post mentions of racism i
mean mentions of you know
toxic masculinity patriarchy they
flooded the game
with all of this and all of the sudden
over the last 10 years
you have this culture where every single
giant corporation
every politician every major media
outlet
every movie in hollywood everything has
been flooded
with an obsession over
race and gender and all of this stuff
and and
to me i think it's a look at this cia
commercial the other day
i mean is this not our torturers are
are going to be talking about how
inclusive they are
you know come on wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you got to see
the game here but let me just say the
game
is to distract from the issues that
really matter
which is power violence authoritarianism
and to get everybody pitted against each
other in this culture war
and they have we have to tip our hat to
them because they have done an
incredibly
successful job they've done a good job
at it can we get like a ryan long style
skit
where it's like guantanamo bay inmates
in jumpsuits being like
you know for the longest time the
torturers that were coming that's a
really good idea
they were white guys they were white
guys and i love ryan by the way he's
great
and then there's playing a good music
and then you have a guy being like we
feel like we're finally a part of
history we're so excited
and then like you know a black woman
comes in and she's carrying like the rag
and the bucket and like
putting the gloves on and the guy's like
bending over and he's like it just feels
good
it's just better now it's just it's just
so much better but that's but that's
what it is
but it's it's if you think about it it's
a great deal i mean if you're like
you know jp morgan chase or bank of
america and they're
you know basically your deal is think
about it right you have like uh like
50 000 angry kids outside chanting
we are the 99 to these bankers
and the deal you've been able to make
the left ultimately is
how about we send all of our white execs
to diversity training
and they're i mean yeah they may not say
this but they're basically like
deal and we will go focus on all this
other stuff and they didn't have to do
anything else think about that
think about we are the 99 they were
literally saying
99 of this country which is all the
white people all the black people all
the asian people
now they're literally saying yeah but
not the majority like
it is split the country and by the and
they didn't even mean 99
it's even more than that because what
they really meant was 99.9
what they really meant was that people
who own banks
and and hedge funds versus all the rest
of us i mean like
no hold on at the time they were talking
about mark zuckerberg
they this is the funniest thing i'll
tell you my one of my favorite
days most memorable at occupy wall
street was
they were being censored and suppressed
and they were like you know the media
won't cover this
so we have to print our own physical
newspapers we have to use these these
other social networks if he was live
streaming to get our message out
and they use twitter and they use
facebook but it was funny because they
were complaining about the top one
percent
and they literally put up a shrine to
steve jobs when he died
yeah yeah i'm like what it would it was
not a good person
but the point is that but this was the
thing about occupy wall street right
they they didn't have all of the answers
and there were these like hypocrisies
and silly things like that but in
essence they were right
like the banks had just gotten bailed
out and
and it was during the worst you know
recession
since the great depression you're gonna
bail out these guys and then they kept
their bonuses
i mean it was so blatantly corrupt and
for them to call that out
was right and they were focused at at
least
one of the power sources like the big
banks they were really focused at some
something that actually mattered and at
the same time or at least
around the same time you had the tea
party movement
that was going on where these these
right-wingers were coming out in the
streets
and the right-wingers were saying you
know the government is way too big it
spends way too much money it's too
corrupt we're taxed too much we borrow
too much the debt's out of control
there's a problem
and the left-wingers are over here
saying you know bailing out the banks is
immoral they're getting
all of these prophets and none of that
and it was almost like
i've said this before on my podcast it
was almost like they were holding
two sides of the same pendant necklace
and it was only a matter of time for the
left and right to come together and be
like you know these ideas don't
contradict each other at all
they actually go right in line with each
other however now it got
all broken up occupy very quickly went
woke
it was only a matter of like a week or
two when the facilitators they called
himself come in and start saying oh
white people aren't allowed to speak
and it drove you know you know there
were libertarians conservatives there oh
yeah
i know i remember one of the in the
first week there was like a 60 year old
couple with an american flag sitting
there complaining about all the same
things
you know the banks got bailed out were
being corrupted and everyone was in
agreement
i mean i i met luke it was occupied the
fed there was occupy the fight was going
along
that was alongside october wall street
those were all the libertarians who
supported
because this was the ron paul days so
the libertarians were trying to come in
there and try to like they weren't
hold on they were trying to teach them a
little bit like hey if you hate the
banks there's this one
yeah they weren't trying to do anything
they were there
i was there in the first week they were
there luke rutkowski was there
ron paul guy i met him there we talked
about these things great conversations
between libertarians conservatives and
liberals
and then very quickly the ultra okay men
took over the meetings and said white
people weren't allowed to talk anymore
and i remember this one white dude i
knew who was an anarchist started crying
and left
and so these people started leaving and
it was stripping away the core of the
movement now
many of these occupy people who followed
me or friended me at the time
are championing the fbi's raid on
giuliani and facebook and twitter
massive multinational
corporations suppressing dissent they've
never had principles
they were going along with the tide and
they were manipulated now
let's go super chats see what the
audience has to say so if you haven't
already
smash that like button go to timcast.com
to become a member
and get access to exclusive segments
from the tim cast irl
show if you go to times.com you'll see
the top right corner we actually have a
stripe option now stripe is amazing i
hear uh
they're they're i i really like stripe
um
it's i know a lot of people didn't like
paypal so so there you go but uh anyway
smash that like button subscribe share
the show if you really like it let's uh
let's read some of these super chats
michael brogan says friday nights baby
always the best guests cheers dave
cheers tim kest irl team
we are having a crew come out hopefully
next week to help us clean out
the garage skatepark so if you've seen
the vlog
we've got or you've seen my instagram
posts we have this big park slash venue
we call it the grind bar
and we we have some work that has to be
done with clearing out this like really
awful gross insulation
because we still have a lot of work to
do and uh after that we're going to
start
we're trying to get as fast as go as
fast as we can friday night
live events where we wouldn't just be
having this show at we'd actually swap
over and have music
and comedy and members are actually
going to be able to buy tickets to come
out
and we'll do this hopefully every single
week
we gotta get things cleaned up then once
we do we can get the computers installed
the camera's installed and then we got
to do a major upgrade on this studio so
it takes time unfortunately but that's
the plan man all right christian
uh jumgochian says when i was 17
and a dumb high schooler i wanted to be
a cop seven years later i'm glad i
didn't do it also here's 27
for the 2700 you donated to the cat's
surgery good guy tim over here
keeping his promises y'all rock yeah so
yesterday someone super chatted their
cat needed surgery
and i said by the end of the show this
will be
done and a lot of people did donate
still a large amount was left over so i
don't add
i actually wanted to start a nonprofit a
while ago we talked about it where we um
basically pay for animal surgeries
because i know a lot of people who have
had like a cat or a dog
it's like two grand yeah to like save
the animal's life
and they're like i just don't have that
money so like what are you gonna do let
your pet die
i'm like maybe we can set something up i
don't know yeah all right let's see
where we're at
c hennessey says tim you should get
louis rossman from youtube on he's an
nyc business owner who can't
who can't plead guilty or ask for court
date for a fine that was given on bs
unclear law
could pay more in fines if he uh if he
can't get in contact
right to repair yeah i saw this
apparently the website didn't work so he
couldn't actually do anything then they
call him like you're in trouble and he's
like i can't even go on the wedding
website doesn't work like what am i
supposed to do
and there's no in person because of
kovid so it's just like
new york's imploding
logan brown says how are you enjoying
rural living
you know i guess it it is rural
i suppose it could be more rural but
it's the best sub rural
i walk outside into my deck and i just
like fire a an arrow from my compound
bow and just hit a target
i can just like do that every morning
whenever i want it's fantastic it's
nothing so good outside yeah you wait
you
you go outside fresh air we have here's
the crazy thing
y'all city folk drinking that nasty
fluoride water aren't you
not us we got we got our own water
source yes fresh well water
and it's and we got a really great
system uh we have like one of the
highest quality
you know home systems it's got the uv
light and everything
none of that gross fluoride water with
you know
copper and rusted pipes yeah russet
pipes
carter felder says have you read spiral
dynamics by don beck and christopher
cohen
i haven't have any of you that sounds
fascinating though the spiral man
evb jones says this super chat was paid
for by unemployment benefits
i could go back to work but the entire
state government is telling me not to
they're literally paying me not to give
them what they paid for yeah what if we
supplanted unemployment with ubi so that
you could still work
you just still got the money but then
you just you don't lose it if you go to
work it doesn't
it doesn't work but unemployment doesn't
work either it would just be better
less so i just feel like if you're if
you're asking
look like i was saying before the
government is just giving you taxpayer
money
if you want to ask for help from the
people who do work and are paying taxes
how about this radical idea ask for the
help
and if they want to give you the help
they can and if people in your community
go oh there's this guy who's trying to
work but he's out of work
we can pull some money together and help
him but why do you get to
through government force somebody who
has to produce something and has to go
to work
to just give you money for nothing
that's that's a
cooperation versus competition argument
but to ian's point about why can't you
supplement ubi
let's say somebody is uh a base
they make screws you know you need
screws so that you can build wood
objects and the person who the company
that makes screws pays 15 bucks an hour
so they start saying everybody we're
looking to hire people we pay 15 bucks
an hour and you'll probably end up
making you know
two grand per month the guy goes i get a
thousand bucks a month doing nothing
so why should i do work and only get a
little bit more and they say well we're
supplementing
your income so you'll get an extra
you'll have three thousand per month and
they're like but i can live off of a
thousand and do
nothing and i can so that do stuff in my
free time and make money under the table
yes and then the business says okay well
then how much do we have to pay you
to make you want to work here on top of
a thousand you already get and they're
like i don't know okay
can we give you three thousand a month
they go all right then i'll have four
grand all right i'll take the job
what's happening is now the company has
to raise the cost of all the screws
then the contractor comes in says we
gotta build a house man screws just went
up you know 33 percent why
because in order to incentivize people
who don't need to work you got to pay
them a lot more than you would pay
someone who doesn't have any money
because of
competition you instead of having to
offer him for three grand instead you
just find someone else that want to do
it for two
why would they why would someone it's
like you said earlier
when the government it pays someone 16
an hour any business
that is offering you a job is saying
i'll give you one dollar an hour for
full-time work yeah
so if someone's already getting a
thousand bucks you're saying i'll give
you an additional seven dollars an hour
to work full-time
and most people are going to be like i'd
rather just like
sit on the beach one other like
logistical problem that i see with the
idea of ubi is that quite often
proponents of it take for granted
the idea that we've uh abolished all
other forms
of handouts which any time is a
libertarian anytime i say let's abolish
the welfare state it's like oh well
that's so impractical but for some
reason when you're proposing ubi
you just get to take it as a given that
we've abolished all these other forms of
welfare
so if we have already done the work of
abolishing all these other forms of
welfare
then we've really changed the mentality
in this country that people would be
willing to accept that
because what happens when somebody okay
so you get a thousand dollars a month or
something like that we've abolished all
other forms of welfare
uh single mom not working with three
kids
she blew her thousand dollars now she's
destitute what about that
aren't we right back at the exact same
place where we were before what are we
going to do to take care of if a mom was
making 1800 a month
uh for whatever reason and then you were
going to supplant the 1000. she'd only
get 800 left
she wouldn't lose at all but you could
only she would only supply it
up to the base but then if that's the
case then we have all of the same
incentive problems that we had with the
welfare states to begin with
except you could she's not getting
anything you could reduce the initial
so like the first thousand you don't
have like you'd get rid of unemployment
um you and then does that do you know
what i'm saying
no okay it doesn't work yeah well this
none of it works that's the point is
it's busted so let's try yes
plug a hole here you can't calm down you
can't it's like being like
why can't i just eat ice cream for the
rest of my life
now i understand there's a problem with
sugar and fats but let's find out how to
eat ice cream you can't do it you're
going to pay people
these vitamins a month then why why
punish them for getting a job on top of
that it doesn't make any sense to me
oh okay i understand the point there and
there certainly is an incentive problem
with telling someone
that they lose their money if they start
getting a job but to the flip side of
that
now you're giving taxpayer money to
people who don't need it now you're
giving taxpayer money to people who
you know may not even be asking for it i
mean
i don't know if we're gonna talk about
repealing the welfare state
let's just do what obviously makes sense
which is repeal it
may why are we giving these blood-soaked
monsters in washington dc control of our
tax dollars
to try to do the right thing with look
over this last year
in america's greatest moment in need
like
when we really were on our knees as a
country
what did they do they robbed the
american people and bailed out all of
the biggest corporations in the country
the banks got extended trillions in easy
loans every big corporation that was
politically connected
got hundreds of billions of dollars we
got like what a crummy twelve hundred
dollars going out
why are we trusting this mechanism which
is we all know
all of us know rotten to the core filled
with corrupt people
if we either people are good enough to
take care of those who are in need
or they're not and if they're not
they're certainly not good enough to
vote in blood-soaked monsters who are
then going to take care of the people
there's one possibility too right and
it's that if the government give
everybody a thousand bucks a month from
taxpayers
you know everyone you know pays taxes
they likely would not be able to do that
because i think it would exceed the gdp
or
just be a tremendous strain so they
probably print or borrow but let's say
everyone's still desperate for work
because a thousand dollars a month
doesn't cut it
now you're going to see businesses being
like we only pay five bucks an hour take
it or leave it
you're already getting a thousand
government you don't need anything from
us sorry that's it you could reduce
minimum wage yeah
well or what would happen is
hyperinflation from ubi would result in
stagnant minimum wage the left would
then demand the minimum wage go up and
it would just be constant command
economy
it just it just doesn't work it makes
little sense
it makes no sense the i i say when i say
little
i get it you know a child says why don't
we just like give people money so they
can have food because like we have so
much food
it's like bro cause the economy doesn't
work that way the
what the dollar represents right now is
a few things arguably represents the
energy required for for for labor
so it could represent like petroleum the
petro dollar um
but in terms of labor in the united
states we have a very service
sector-based economy
the dollar the energy behind it is what
people are willing how much labor people
are willing to exchange for
labor how much does a petroleum engineer
how much time do they want to work in
order to have someone serve them a
cheeseburger at a restaurant
they probably don't value that that a
whole lot in fact we can get kiosks to
do it
so the issue is when we talk about just
raising minimum wages
or giving people money you will just
increase the cost
of the lowest level of labor that people
don't respect as it is
doctors are like why should so there's
this meme that goes around
where it's a guy like i'm an electrical
engineer and when i hear that
fast food workers want to make the same
amount as me i say congratulations
we all deserve a living wage and it's
the stupidest argument because
an electrical engineer who's probably
not making all that much you know
relative
you know to other jobs doesn't want to
have to work for five hours to be able
to buy
a a chicken dinner these people are
saying i work hard
i've established myself in my career i
should be able to provide for my family
and by working harder gain more to give
my family a better life
that means after 10 years of training
being apprenticed now i'm a journeyman
now i'm a master
i'm making more money and somebody
is is going to spend the same amount of
time in a fast food restaurant
to earn the same thing they do now the
argument for the left is but everyone
deserves a living wage
the problem then is people will say why
work hard to become a specialist or
master
if we're only going to get access to the
same things again the left argument is
that people will be fulfilled by taking
these jobs
that's true for some people but not true
for everybody and i always ask my lefty
friends this
how many people do you know want to be
famous musicians and they're like oh a
ton
how many of them are good enough to
actually do it none of them
and how many of them if you gave them
money would quit their jobs and just
play garbage music outside trying to be
a rock star
probably all of them yeah people have
and then on the flip side of that right
like you know um there are these jobs
like being a garbage man usually pays
like
fairly decently because you know no one
really wants to do that
but you have the only way to entice
people into it is to say like well look
you can make 80k a year and in 10 years
garbage trucks will be ai and the
primary
you know argument of the smartest people
who propose ubi
is ai right that's what they're saying
that's why
billionaires that's supporting well okay
because then you have
it is a false argument then you have the
richest people getting free resources
from those who are still forced that's
how it's gonna be anyway working hard
doesn't make you rich
in this world but working hard
shouldn't make you rich i mean i could
go outside and lift a boulder over my
head and drop it for 12 hours in a row
and i'm working really really hard i
shouldn't get rich from that because i'm
not providing any value
hold on if it's attached to a gravity
generator well okay then now now we're
talking
but i would just say in the the argument
and i think this is actually the most
flawed argument for ubi which is one of
the arguments that you're not brought up
i know you're not making it you're just
you're just saying that this is one of
the arguments which is basically
that well technological developments are
going to take away all of the jobs that
exist
now and so we have to replace them with
something the major major flaw in that
argument
is that if you looked at what technical
technological advancements have already
taken away in terms of jobs they're
almost
all gone i mean if you look at the jobs
from 1890
there's i mean what what percentage of
society was in agricultural work
compared to now it's probably 80 to
three percent or something like that
but to be fair you know that the city
used to have
poop departments to clean up horse poop
well san francisco is bringing them back
but that's exactly the same but the
point is that you if you're going to say
that
if if somebody in the year 1890 was like
oh my god these
automobiles are coming in and this is
going to put out the horse and buggy
driver out of work
you know if you were to sit down and
explain to them like and they said well
what jobs are people going to do and you
were like well how about graphic design
and how about audio engineer this would
be impossible to explain to somebody
you know a 130 years ago but the point
is that in the future we won't know what
the jobs are going to be that this
technology will create the problem of
jobs the problem is
you can't take a petroleum engineer
who is you know 50 who still needs to
work and be like
go go be a go learn to code they're
going to be like i can't learn to do
that are you nuts
so that means my specialty which becomes
obsolete so this is a hole in the system
that
no but there still are uh peripheral
jobs
related to it yeah they don't require
knowledge of how to code well look it's
a hole in the system
in a sense i mean it's like this is part
of like
it's creative destruction right so if
you
owned a kodak store when
digital cameras came out like i'm not
denying that that really sucked for you
i mean there's like there are people who
like you know it was like oh
i make typewriters and that sucks that
computers came out
but it also it doesn't destroy the
economy just just like
there were lots more jobs created i want
you to imagine something everyone's
listening right now the year
is you know 1999
or maybe no no it's 2004 i don't know
what year and there is a
young man he's 23 and he's wearing a
blue polo shirt
and he's got a tear a single tear coming
from his left eye as this is
wearing a beanie is this the story as
the regional manager for blockbuster
enters his store puts his hand on his
shoulder and says son
it's over and he's been working there
for years his passion everyone in the
neighborhood knew him
he was smiling jim they'd come and he'd
be like what's the movie is today jimmy
be like oh let me show you the new
releases with a smile on his face for
years
this young man and then one day they
came in and said the dream has come to
an end
and then all that's left now is this old
decaying building with this
weird ticket logo and it's just a
rotting decay and
jim shows up now and he's now in his 40s
and he looks there and he stands across
the street
with a beer gut his hair is thinning and
gone you know his kids are walking past
him and they're like come on dad and he
goes just a second
and he looks across the street at the
old blockbuster so he raises his left
hand
and then he just remembers if that guy
could have pushed a button and stopped
netflix
he may have which terrifies me because
that indicates an incentive to stop or
slow innovation i think okay
that's why you don't want workers to
have control over things like this this
is
what you just mentioned is the great
flaw in democratic socialism
is that if you have like workers having
control over innovation yeah they're
going to vote against
okay okay so so let's go back okay so
he's raising his left hand looking
across
the blockbuster and then he scowls
he's angry i'm go we're going home kids
and then he he works tirelessly in his
basement
welding and his kids are like dad what
are you doing not now
and his wife is like it's been weeks
he's not showering what's happening and
then finally in his basement he goes
i've done it and he hits a giant red
button
and opens up a time vortex and he goes
back in time and he finds the founder of
netflix
and he's shaking and holding the gun and
he's like you took everything from me
and the netflix guy goes i don't even
know you and that's the story of how the
alternate timeline where blockbuster
never
never went out of business i would watch
that movie if it was sold
at blockbuster but only there see but
but just the point
the goal isn't just jobs you know what i
mean like the
goal is prosperity the goal is more
productivity in a higher productive
capacity
i mean if we were i think this is old
like frederick bastiat example i forget
exactly how it goes but
if the that the sun is putting the
candle makers out of it like you know
the candle makers could sell a lot more
if we didn't have this sun the whole
time
but if you could just imagine right
let's say oxygen
which is something we all need to live
but we don't think about and it's not
scarce so we just have it
imagine we all had to work five hours a
day for oxygen
like there's some type of physical work
had to be done so that there was enough
for us to breathe
well we would have way more jobs but we
would also be way poorer because we'd be
working for something that we already
have for free now
so the the goal is to produce more and
more
with less and less yeah they're just let
me read the super chat reserve
content yes we got we got a super chat
from rad number two he says i work a
union gig and we are desperate for help
starting at 100k per year with benefits
and people would rather sit on their
butts and get free money
also dave smith for president hey there
you go thinking about it
i'm into it yeah oh yeah aren't you
running or something is it
i said i'm i'm thinking about running on
the libertarian party yeah because in
2020
well listen i'm you know you you brought
it up i think last time i was here and i
know you brought it up before and you're
right to that meme
of libertarian ideas versus libertarian
candidates
but the truth is there's no reason for
it to be like that
and there have been great libertarian
candidates before ron paul was that guy
harry brown was that guy
and um you know there's just a lot of
the candidates don't really know how to
talk
about liberty right and um if no one
else will do it good then i'll do it
all right so john mob says tim you can't
quit and be approved for unemployment
there's an investigation process that
does take place and you need to be fired
or laid off to get approved so don't
quit people you will be denied
that is false john you are incorrect you
need a
reason so uh you can work at a job and
quit and still get unemployment so long
as you quit for a valid reason namely uh
you were being harassed your boss you
know
uh did something inappropriate you can
say
i felt threatened at work and i didn't
know how to deal with it because i felt
i felt like there was me retaliation
and they might deny you they might be
like that's not a good enough reason but
you can quit you just need a real reason
and that's the thing a lot of people do
they'll they'll file a complaint at work
and be like this person's making me feel
unsafe
then a week later they'll come back and
say i still feel unsafe there's no way
to resolve someone saying something like
i feel unsafe
this person's doing it and then when the
business can't do anything about your
fake problem you quit
and you say yeah i quit because they
were threatening me and they couldn't do
anything about it
and they'll be like okay
also if you are fired for cause you also
might not be able to get unemployment so
like if you do something inappropriate
and it's documented and try and get
fired and then say i want an employment
they might be like yeah well like
you were streaking through the the halls
of the business you don't get
unemployment
it's it's just about whether it's your
fault or not
so you can quit dakota smith says just
bought the to the moon shirt longtime
viewer keep up the struggle appreciate
it that's right
if you go to timcast.com click the store
we have this amazing new doge
shirt it's a shiba holding cash and it
says to the moon and there's coins
everywhere
and that one's probably for a while i
love that one it's great
all right let's see let's get some new
super chats
uh-oh slenzer says slenzer
dave malus may be your press secretary
but tim poole is chief of staff all day
ian can tag along and liz's
communications director to keep malice
on a leash
i don't know about chief of staff i
don't know what that sounds doesn't
sound like something i would do
i feel like we could find a more uh
creative job for you
chief of staff sounds boring yeah you
want something you're a fun guy
head up intelligence or something yeah
yeah yeah like director of national
intelligence
yeah there you go i just feel like you
couldn't you couldn't be worse than the
previous ones
i'd be i'd be much too libertarian i'd
be like
that's what that's what we're looking
for just be releasing the documents like
so
that like the like the head of the c i
would walk in and be like all right we
got some very serious intel they hand me
the report yeah that's interesting it's
like let me let me tweet this real quick
and uh
what are you doing i'm just tweeting out
this to the public so they can see
what's going on i'm sorry dude i'm going
to get so many likes on this
the public has a right to know it's like
yeah no i don't know man i understand
that there's a real need for like
confidentiality
classified stuff and like war and
conflict so that's why i don't want to
go anywhere near that stuff
all right ian mitchell says with
ethereum having moved away from proof of
work
miners and those interested in mining
should look into vertcoin
the new vert hash algorithm is asic
resistant and very gpu friendly
vertcoin's one click miner makes it a
great
a great intro to mining everybody's got
a new a new coin
mark jensen says the atf just posted a
proposed rule change redefining what a
firearm is
would make millions of gun owners felons
overnight
wow oh there you go
chris demand says ian took your advice
last
am or l took your advice i'm starting a
new political party the southern
secessionist syndicate party
check us out i don't know what that is
yeah something about southern
secessionists just has a little bit of a
bad idea
i don't remember advising that i mean
i'm all i'm all for it
but it's just it has this historical
it's a peaceful divorce keep that in
mind
the federal government will blockade any
port it has to
no i don't know look at the soviet union
they broke up right
because they invaded afghanistan and i
think and destroyed their economy that
was before they broke up
yeah and then they broke up too bad i
like that band
wraith customs firearm says the
financial advice thing started because
someone owning stock a would say
buy stock a get others to buy it to
spike value then dump it
get rich while others get screwed love
the show shout out to my small business
wraithcustomsfirearms.com hey thanks for
the super chat
paul mikesner says tim i'd like to
invite you and the crew to the ivey
quadruple eight range day shoot exotics
full autos for free
meet the majority of gun youtube
channels prez of goa fpc
industry peeps wanted to invite you
three years ago but was on
nolan's tenant cancelled last year i'll
email you at midnight uh
is it near where we're at cause that
sounds great can we film it that'd be
fun
some uh belt fed full auto or something
dr doctor says ubi is a concept is
probably more
25 years out unless we have quick
advancement in automation
and robotics and it's cost effective
versus human labor
as a former atc in the army i watched
more and more automation even in my
field
plus advanced drones look into t-a-i-s
i've been talking about this stuff for
decades i was like a teenager i was like
16.
and i felt there's a serious problem
that you could dedicate your life to
your to your country to your community
working hard to be the master at a
certain job and when it becomes obsolete
we just kick you out
it's like sorry you can't have access to
goods now because through no faulty of
your own technology advanced
which creates a problem however luddites
aren't good either
just saying like the horse and buggy
industry is being destroyed by by big
auto
so it's a challenge unfortunately the
problem with ubi is that
some people would not work while others
work extremely hard and what do you
think is going to happen when rural
farmers are
are busting their asses and people in
the city are doing nothing
eventually going to be like i am done
being your servant
and working hard so that you get free
stuff well like i was saying before i
would just say that the concept of ubi
in essence already exists like the idea
that well we have this starting point
that no one falls behind i mean like
it's a rebrand right like talk to
someone in central africa compare our
life to that we have that we we
live with that already so the only
question that's important is
what is going to lift this whole tide up
more and more
and so i think that honestly like yeah
you could look at the guy who loses
his job because technology changes but
what about the
50 guys who gained a job when the
technology changed the question is
what makes us richer and richer and
richer and i don't think that that's
government-handled
um i think it was darwin said it's not
the smartest of the species that
survives but the one that's the most
adaptable to change
right and you can see that in automation
yep and people are figuring out how to
be more independently creative and
generate financial freedom on their own
i mean that's that's what you got to do
more than that this is a this is
a good one vash spectre says massive gas
shortage is due
to lack of truck drivers to deliver fuel
market is down
300 000 drivers and high 90
turnover i drive 70 hours a week i would
do more if the government would let us
wow there you are 12.50 a week if you
join
wow so i'm glad i got an electric car i
bought a tesla
because i'm like i don't want to sit
around and wait for the next gas
shortage like i wasn't around for it in
the 80s
i guess was a gas shortage people
remember it i guess i remember hearing
stories about people waiting in line it
was like odds and even license plate
numbers to try and get gas on certain
days
i saw one in uh new york during
hurricane sandy were you guys there
oh yeah dude that was crazy that was a
couple weird couple days people waiting
all day for for
to felt their tank one time i haven't
literally hurricane sandy was one of the
weirdest things i've ever seen in my
life being in midtown manhattan
and it's like country black you know
like you can't see your hand in front of
your face and you're
walking around with flashlights and
stuff did a stand-up show by candlelight
oh
it was wacky nice tyler adam says hey
tim one person i'd love to
be on the show would be charles
hoskinson of the cardano foundation
he's got his own youtube channel he's
he's politically intellectual and the
creator of cardano co-creator of
ethereum
his location is in colorado and worth
the interview interesting
full disclosure i do have bitcoin
ethereum and cardano we talked about
this the other day i also have dogecoin
it's at 69 cents now 0.69 whatever it is
yeah but was everyone's going to sell
once like it's a dollar after saturday
when elon talks about it
it's going to be a huge dump is coming
but it's like yeah he actually there's a
video of him i saw yesterday he was like
doge is a joke
invest responsibly and i would never
tell anyone their fortune in this
kuro taran says regarding your the a
video you posted earlier in the day i'm
from wisconsin
we have castle doctrine here so the
arrest of the man for conducting a show
of force when rioters threatened him was
a wrongful arrest dare i say illegal
no but does that mean the police broke
the law and arrested a homeowner who was
being threatened by a raucous crowd
doesn't sound right that doesn't sound
like something the police would do
they wouldn't arrest the the the
law-abiding citizen in his own home who
was defending himself from a group of
people who had previously been a house
that was set on fire
that'd be so strange weird it's almost
as if the police
are taking the side of the riders
because like i said last year
the police will show up see a group of
rioters
and a homeowner and be like it's easier
to arrest one person in their home than
it is to deal with
60 violent people and that they're
they're susceptible to
political pressure and that when it
comes to it like there are a lot of cops
right a lot of cops are not sympathetic
to these left-wing
rioters that's not what police are but
they know their higher-ups are going to
get them in trouble they might be on the
news they might be on this and so they
just go with what's easier and
there's no reason to suspect i mean just
look at the 20th century do you think
that the enforcement arm of the state
is not willing to just kind of do what
is expedient even at the violation of
of human rights i mean we're not
different creatures than the russians or
the germans or any of them it's the same
structure it's a state and an armed
agent of the state enforcing the rules
bear in mind says i got laid off and was
making 9.50 a week from unemployment
and my dad who didn't get laid off was
only making 800 for 60 hours
he wasn't happy wow that's why ubi
doesn't work because the people who
still have to work because humans are
still needed for labor
are going to revolt against those in the
capital who aren't working but are
getting access to their resources
imagine if every day actually this is
this is true
imagine if every day you built a
birdhouse and the government came and
just took half your birdhouses away and
gave it people who weren't working hey
that's kind of happening today isn't it
no no it'd be like if you were building
a birdhouse and they came and gave you
birdhouse parts that you didn't need
as they were giving everyone else
birdhouse parts no but see the flaw in
that logic is thinking that there is
this unlimited
supply of birdhouse parts they have to
be made
so the idea is like if somebody's
working their tail off
and making two thousand dollars a week
for it and then somebody else does
nothing and gets one thousand dollars a
week for it
that is going to build resentment from
the people who are producing the wealth
it's this simple bro imagine you pay
rent to live in a house
and some dude sleeping on your couch and
he doesn't work and he's eating all your
food
he better be paying me half of his
youtube he's not paying you anything he
better be if he's living in my house
this is what ubi is it's putting a
layout on your couch who isn't working
but is getting a portion of your stuff
if you are working every day to make
something of value for society
and there are someone who is not doing
anything that money has to come from
somewhere
and if they can't take it from you
because you'll freak out they will print
money devaluing your money and your
resources
giving it to this person and then shows
up and say ian i'll give you i'll give
you 100 bucks
of imagine this you're like you better
give me half your ubi if you're living
in my house and he laughs and goes it's
your money anyway i don't care
the money came from your labor sure you
could have half of it i'll take your
stuff
you're still losing your stuff to a
layabout no in that situation people
i'd be making more than i was losing in
that situation i think the problem is
that they're printing money the federal
reserve can just endlessly print money
right
where do you think they're gonna get the
money from ubi for from endless money
for
they want to test corporations aoc said
we should be deficit spending
huh i think uh andrew yang said that we
need to tax corporations for uh what
were they vets
that yeah value-added tax because i just
don't understand how we can even talk
about taxing corporations just stop
giving them taxpayer money can we work
on that first
once we achieve that then maybe i'll
entertain the conversation about whether
we're going to then take
their money back you know it's like if
you're talking about giving someone a
blood transfusion
but you're actively draining blood from
them like okay could you stop doing that
you first do that and then we could yeah
i know but that's that's what we're
doing right now
we're taxing working people and giving
that money to corporations
and then having these abstract
conversations about whether the
corporations are paying their fair share
how about they just have to survive or
fail on their own at least
oh starting point dude we're paying 20
trillion back to fannie mae
and freddie mac over 20 years or
something 20 trillion dollars
all right madison mcafee says i was
wrongfully arrested
to an fta for a court case i went to for
a noise violation
and even got the charge dropped but they
didn't file it 36 hours in dekalb
county jail minus one thousand dollars
was told i couldn't sue because they'd
claim negligence that's
justice system wow yup
that's right aiden b
donian dunyan says hey tim love the show
and the guests you have here in oklahoma
they banned critical theory
and now the dems are trying to argue
that banning it violates their first
amendment rights
let me just make something clear the
first amendment doesn't protect the
state's
rights to speak it protects the people's
right to speak and it protects their
right to speak from the government
from the state i think it's funny that
these schools are like this is a free
speech issue
we don't have to force the state to say
anything we can we can tell the state
they're not allowed to speak yeah the
people can speak
well that's like i mean saying like if
you banned a public school from teaching
that prayer
two plus two equals five or prayers like
whatever you wanna call it i mean like
no you have every
you know it's reasonable to set
standards isn't it funny how they're
like they want to restrict prayer in
schools
and now they're acting like we should be
able to restrict the things like we
couldn't restrict speech in schools like
prayer is protected under the first
amendment but by the way critical race
theory is just their prayer
exactly you know what i mean their
religion straight up
yup a
skidlove says learned about dave through
comedy and now i'd vote for him for
president
smith gabbard 2024 with malice as press
secretary let's go
alex jones wants to get involved too can
is there is there an amount of money i
have to earn and spend to make michael
malus the press secretary
no that's this is uh we worked this out
already he said
he will do it for one bitcoin a month no
no no
i don't mean to pay a salary i mean how
do we actually get an administration to
win
that results in a malice press secretary
that's going to cost more than a bitcoin
bill a billion dollars that's going to
be that's going to be more because
you're fighting the establishment so you
need like
10 billion but it's only what 10 billion
could buy you which is air time wasn't
this
what we what it's going to start as is
michael malus just being
the communication director of a campaign
which will be fun
enough on its own just him just wrecking
everybody you have to you have to
run for the libertarian party because
then you would actually be getting press
coverage
and michael malus would be the
communications director well this is the
plan this is the plan sir
but then i have to you're not officially
running for anything as a libertarian
that's right you must i am uh i am
seriously considering it and i'll tell
you if i do it
it's going to be an epic campaign
it's going to be it's going to be
something that that there
there won't have been a libertarian uh
run like this since ron paul because i
will utilize everyone
michael malus like you like everybody
who's good at what they do
will be doing it and it's not it's not
about like my thing isn't like
oh i want to achieve political power and
then use it for this or that
the whole point is to just really
spread a message and like you like you
always say like the libertarian message
is great
and that's what i think needs to be out
there and to call out all these power
brokers for their hypocrisy there
there's there's contradictory
libertarian messages you know what i
mean there are pro-borders and
anti-borders libertarians
because people disagree on the extent of
what to what libertarian really means i
guess
well okay sure there are people who
disagree on that but the major problem
even with the border crisis is all
government created
i mean the whole thing is like okay so
we have a war on drugs so then there's
these people smuggling all these drugs
in
then we have a welfare state that
incentivizes all of these people in
there we subsidize that then we
subsidize the war against immigrants
then we have easy birthright citizenship
which subsidizes people coming in
the whole thing is a government mess to
begin with so i i'm with you i wouldn't
like suggest like
right now under current conditions we
just have open borders but i would
recognize that the whole thing is a
government mess to begin with yep
and the problem is always the government
the problem is always the rulers
it's kind of like every time they plug a
hole another hole bursts out yeah they
keep trying to just
you know maybe just be like nah you need
to you know like let things yeah we need
a new system we
like a decentralized social network
system that is government-backed
uh yeah we can build floating islands
automotive power i mean
we need a decentralized more like uh
automatic system of of border security
i'm thinking like auto defense turret
50 50 bmg full auto i'm kidding
well i was look i was saying the last
time i was on this show i really
believe this that decentralization some
type of scaling back
of the power of the federal government
is like
just in a medical sense the only thing
that could save this country
because we are on a suicide mission
right now and the culture war and all of
this is related to it it's everyone
jocking for position
for who controls the federal government
that's why it spikes every four years
when it's your president or my
president's going to win
the debt is out of control the money
printing's out of control
this thing is obvi we're obviously going
off the cliff and the only answer here
is to scale that well that that's a
pretty solid start
but scale this thing back more local
control more community control
less federal control and that's the only
thing that can say
you can build voting apps where people
can choose where their tax dollars go
yeah and things
all right we got super chat from doctor
doctor he says what i'm saying
uh i think means seeing as an uh is what
i'm saying is as an air traffic
controller with a
which is a highly complex situationally
aware job it was becoming more and more
automated
if that kind of work is becoming
automated even coding is getting closer
to being more automated
and needing less coders well coding like
could you imagine uh
what's what's what's the standard
copyright like basic or binary i suppose
could you imagine like hard coding
something in just binary no then we make
coding languages that basically simplify
the process and become easier and easier
c sharp have you seen in your experience
with mines any
advancements in ai writing the code oh
there was a new
uh ai like programming language that
could generate programs automatically
that mit just put out
but yeah i mean that's happening code
that creates code
yeah well i mean it's just you're you're
making more advanced code
so it simplifies to where look look at
website development
when i started making websites i was
doing actual html and things like that
right way back in the day
and i started animating in flash and i
was like oh this is great now we're at a
point where it's like you drag and drop
things
you know it's like element element
element and then boop just drag and drop
my favorite thing is when like some of
these geniuses will come out and they're
like
okay this ai thing is really dangerous
but then they just go back to working on
the ai
after that like it's like we can't even
control it we're like yeah all right
this might be a problem but i'm gonna
keep going
ethical question about ai if you make
the software code free
for the ai so you know what it's doing
you can watch its software progress
can you make it so it doesn't make
itself proprietary or is ai just in
general can just disregard its own
ai is not so self-knowledgeable that it
can
dictate its own accessibility to
humans i think that people think that ai
is a lot more it there are risks
yeah but it's not like this
alien force of higher intelligence
that's like attacking us
right now i mean we have the capability
to control it
there you go yeah people people think ai
is going to be like skynet
and the terminators they think it's like
ultron in order to end all war
humans must be wiped out in actuality
what's going to happen is
if you turn on an ai to like manage the
economy all of a sudden one day you'd
wake up and there would be no shirts no
shoes
a ridiculous amount of socks and tons of
corn everywhere
and you'd be like wait how do we get to
the point ai's a communist
no because the ai would isn't going to
do what you think it's going to do
it would take probably millions upon
millions of iterations and simulations
to the point where it functions properly
and even then after you know 10 billion
uh calculations it for some reason finds
we've street you know let me slow down
here's why i explain to people in the
future
we have an ai regulated economy you wake
up you're like time to go to work you
look at your phone and it gives you an
address you show up
and there's like a jagged piece of metal
on top of a box you pick it up and your
phone says give it to this guy you walk
over some guy you give it to him
and then he says thank you and he walks
away and then a thousand dollars in your
bank account and you're like i have no
idea what i just did or why
because the ai would be creating jobs
you wouldn't understand or even think of
and then you wouldn't even know what was
what was going on and that's assuming
the ai is actually working in a way to
streamline the process
the ai could only do what its
essentially based program tells it to do
so it might be like corn is food corn is
cheap corn takes less energy than other
forms of energy make corn
and then one day go to the store there's
no beef there's just a bunch of corn and
you're like uh maybe this ai thing isn't
doing what we're supposed to be doing
the problem then is
if that happens over the period of a few
generations people won't realize
and then you'll end up in a future where
there's just only corn and other weird
products and people are eating like
protein cubes because the ai isn't going
to do what you want to do and
here's the best example youtube created
an algorithm for finding the best
content they said what do people like
they love shows that are long
like game of thrones so we need
something that has the right keywords in
it
that's long form content and appeals to
a wide audience so they create this
algorithm what happened
people started people started cranking
out videos of
hitler and the incredible hulk singing
nursery rhymes together with like this
weird crappy cgi
because it was generating more views
those weren't specifically the videos
that were
the result of 10 minute the 10-minute
algorithm but it was because of babies
so the youtube algorithm was like tons
of
you know we get way the largest
percentage of views come from this one
area
they seem to like these these themes
promote these videos
so then people started auto generating
videos and the ones that worked on
youtube were insane mishmash
of garbage nonsense that made no sense
the hulk in a bikini with a
hitler but hitler's actually got boobs
i'm not kidding it's a real video
there and there were thousands upon
thousands of them so the human thought
people like these things program it in
and then the ai over time started
developing a taste for the most insane
nonsense
and then so the humans who were making
those videos were gaming the system
so the humans were smarter than the ai
and were able to no no
they all they knew was this is what was
getting traffic
no but i'm saying the people who were
making those videos with the hitler with
boobs on them and stuff like that like
they were gaming the ai system
he figured out how to do it go on
youtube and search
finger family hitler and you will see
this video
he's he's it's a woman's body with a
bikini with hitler's head with the
incredible hulk
and he's doing tai chi and it's singing
a nursery rhyme that was recorded by
some dude in india into like a
microphone from the 80s
i mean it 100 and this has been a
problem for a long views
this particular video has like 30 or 40
000. but there was a period still more
than it deserves
there were a period there was a period
where there were hundreds of millions of
these videos
because uh there was there was a big
problem where
there was a a trend of videos that were
like little kids getting injections and
urinating
urinating at each other because that's
what was getting traffic
so because of that that's what the
that's what youtube was promoting
people made more and more and more of it
which created a feedback loop the more
they made the more music gots the more
refined into
into a point where insane stuff
dominated youtube and people were
watching this stuff
the same thing is true of politics so
social media creates an algorithm saying
show us the things that that get the
most watch time and have the most
keywords
and what happened was intersectional
feminism so i've explained this before
right
if an article about racism gets x views
and an article about sexism gets y views
an article about racism and sexism gets
x plus y views and in some instances it
gets x y
view so multiplication and so youtube
starts promoting
whatever has the most keywords in it so
when someone would write an article
being like
democratic trans women of color fighting
with republican alt-right neo-nazis
is the fight of our generation it would
get ridiculous amount of clicks
because the algorithm would be like look
at all these keywords feed it out to all
of these people and they would see it
that made people go insane so facebook
was dominated absolutely by police
brutality videos because it got so much
engagement
rage justice people would share it being
like i must do something
then we ended up with the past 10 years
of intersectionality because buzzfeed
huffington post vox mike
all realized that's how you would make
money that's what people wanted
the people didn't really want that
content they were just being fed
it by the algorithms on the social
networks so long story short
we think the ai will be skynet nah it's
just going to scream in your face nazi
50 billion times it's possible that that
was a machine learning algorithm instead
of an artificial intelligence right
i understand the difference so i'd love
to get an ai specialist on here someday
to go deep into
into that like the difference between
machine learning and ai right
they're not the same thing right so uh
anyway if you haven't already
please smash that like button and become
a member at timcast.com we're going to
have
we might have a vlog episode up tomorrow
over at youtube.com
cast castle because we have two actually
but they're kind of the same because we
just
spent the weekend grilling but uh maybe
let's put them up anyway because you
know vlogs or vlogs and
if you guys want to watch it you can
watch it and then we're going to be
filming again so
more stuffs to come in a couple of weeks
we're going to be going out to the range
i think in about a week we'll be going
to the range for one of the vlogs
and uh it'll be fun a lot a lot of gun
stuff
so make sure you check that out go to
timcast.com become a member you can now
use stripe and make sure you go to the
store and buy your
your shiba to the moon shirt it's
greatly appreciated
you can follow this show at
facebook.comcast irl share our videos
and
on instagram at tim cast irl we're live
monday friday at 8 pm so thanks for
hanging out do you want to shout
anything out
dave oh my podcast is a part of the
problem and uh i will uh
if you're interested in my run for
president i will be speaking at the
libertarian party mises caucus event in
pittsburgh on may 14th next week
come out check us out there the mises
caucus libertarian party
that's all hey hey yeah hit me up
minds.com
opman ott m-a-n hit me up let's do this
yo i'm so ready uh i just wish we could
have talked more about the fed the
federal reserve and the bank of
international settlements
we could talk about this a lot more very
deep we'll do it uh and also i think
there's a new
mug is that true is the don't find an
alligator underwater mug
i believe that is up it may actually be
in addition to our shibu inu to the moon
shirt there is a
cross end the ian crossland don't fight
an alligator underwater mug is
also available i didn't know if it was
going to post you want to bring them on
to land
so that you can fight fight them on your
terms you really don't want to fight an
alligator this is a thing that's what
it's a great heart by the way fantastic
art
thank you guys so much net for those are
not familiar we were talking about don't
getting dr
not getting dragged into these troll
arguments where like someone will argue
on twitter
and then as soon as you counter their
argument they'll change the subject and
then ian just goes yeah i don't fight an
alligator underwater
and i was like mine that was very
profound that's a great way to put it
yeah that is yes i'm on land i have
gotten dragged into way too many of
those arguments
yup trying very much to stop they'll be
they'll they'll say something to you
where it's like joe biden's the greatest
and you'll say well i personally take
issue with joe biden's policy on this
and they'll go
yeah well you're a nazi so you you are
bigot
that's the bait it's like you're not
arguing anymore you know don't get
dragged under water with the alligator
you don't want to do it just tell them
you love them and walk away
yeah there you go i i on facebook i
usually just say like because i i don't
like i don't try to i don't insult
people so i'll post something and then
someone will start yelling at me because
people are nasty and i'll just be like
i'm i'm sorry i don't understand why
you're so upset right now
and they'll be like well i'm just saying
and i'll be like that's cool appreciate
it i'm
just you know don't understand why
you're angry well it's like why are we
i'm not yelling at you you're not
yelling at me what's going on why are
you doing it
anyway yeah and then me yes i'm in the
corner i would also like a mug but i
don't have any catchy sayings yet
so until then you guys can just follow
me on twitter at sourpatchlids
and never forget don't fight an
alligator underwater we will see you all
tomorrow or maybe sunday tomorrow or
sunday youtube.comcastcastle
subscribe to our new vlog channel it's
gonna be a lot of fun we're trying to
build like a 40-foot grind rail so we
can do a bunch of silly things on it
and i guess now we have to do stupid
stuff like
allison was like we're gonna get a
swimming pool and then zipline over it
and i'm like
i guess because we gotta film something
so maybe a volleyball net in the pool
i'm into it there we go thanks for
hanging out everybody we'll see you all
next time
you